so remember that thing that uh what was
it uh oh yeah indictment of Donald Trump
well that's not happening it might
happen next week we don't know for sure
but a new letter has surfaced from 2018
stating that Michael Cohen used his own
personal funds to pay off Stormy Daniels
and that Trump in no way instructed him
to do it well we'll go through the
letter because I'll make sure I get all
the details correct but wow that
basically completely exonerates Trump in
the news reporting now is that the
reason the indictment's been delayed is
because this dude Bragg is struggling to
convince a grand jury that Trump did
anything wrong considering this evidence
that's kind of crazy when you consider
that grand jury is basically always
return indictments because indictments
are not criminal trials it's a
preponderance of evidence should we
issue an indictment and then try and
prove they actually did it well they
can't even get that far
so to all the people who are in the chat
saying things like it's a non-story it
won't happen you were correct but but
but for now because they're still saying
that Bragg is desperate for the
attention and he'll probably want to do
something or maybe even just return it
down I don't even know if he needs the
grand jury we will see
we had a bunch of other news too though
so we'll talk about this uh a crazy
story some stores are pulling eggs from
the shelves because they're too
expensive nobody can afford to buy them
so they're just they're just getting rid
of them out right so we'll talk about
that we got some crazy news with Xi
Jinping and Vladimir Putin shaking hands
and signing like a deal that has not
been seen in 100 years and some serious
worries about
yeah yeah I know World War III but this
is a great thread from Josie the redhead
libertarian talking about how all the
major oil producing nations are forming
an alliance without the United States
which basically is gearing up for a new
world order I don't mean the new world
or a new world order in which the Petro
dollar doesn't matter so we'll get into
that but before we do my friends head
over to timcast.com click that join us
button and become a member as a member
you'll get access to uncensored members
only shows we go we put those up Monday
through Thursday just after this main
show at timcast.com and uh Ian had a
great idea to do Collins so we've set up
a Discord server once you're a member
you get access to the Discord server
after six months of being a basic member
or if you sign up for 25 bucks you will
get access to the voice chat to submit
questions and actually call into the
after show and ask us and our guests
questions last night was the first night
with Congressman Troy nails and it was
amazing to have you guys call in and ask
questions and join the conversation I
think that is uh I don't know probably
the coolest thing we've done and Shout
Out Ian it was Ian's idea to do it yeah
man that's brilliant idea brilliant idea
so I build community right so getting
people into a chat room where they can
talk and then actually call in and talk
with our guests it's it's bringing you
know to have like a city member of
Congress be able to talk to some regular
people who are watching the show I think
is absolutely fantastic so uh join up if
you want to be involved in that smash
that like button and also head over to
trashouserecords.com and pre-order
bright eyes it's a little complicated
there's a weird prompt just click
pre-order you can go to purchase options
the official release is the 24th so
that's why it says you know sorry it's
not available but you can still
pre-order it and then Friday we're
putting out the new song bright eyes and
I will just stress as I stressed
yesterday
we've released three songs so far and
all three have charted on Billboard band
camp which is very woke banned us for no
reason nothing in the songs is hate
speech or anything related directly to
individuals in politics it's like
there's like one songs Like a Love Song
and then one song is just about media
but there's nothing explicit in it like
we don't directly say any proper nouns
well the woke people at bandcamp blocked
me on Twitter deleted my account as well
as five times August clearly what we are
doing is whatever we're doing is working
so if you want to support that and
continue to trigger the woke Tech
corporations who are trying to shut us
down pre-order the song we could use
your support but don't forget to smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
joining us tonight to talk about all of
this and a whole lot more especially
some some really crazy stories
pertaining to um
we got a story out of Nebraska a
Democrat is filibustering for weeks
demanding the right to amputate the
genitals of children it's a very very
strange story but this is what Democrats
are all about right now so joining us to
talk about all this is Landon and Robbie
Starbuck great to see you great to be
back welcome thanks for having us yeah
so uh do you want to introduce
yourselves yes I mean I this is I think
my third or fourth time back on the show
so I'm Robbie Starbuck and I had an
election stolen from me
I feel like I'm in an AAA meeting
um you know so follow at Robbie
Starbucks happy to be here one of my
favorite shows but that was the
Republicans removing yes it was the
Republicans it was the Republicans but
they outright removed you that's crazy
yes and I was like Far and Away leading
candidate I mean there was no argument
about that we complained about that
yesterday we were talking with Troy
nails and I'm like the Republican
party's trash look at the stuff anyway I
know I digress uh Landon yeah I'm Landon
Starbuck I'm Robbie's wife I also run a
non-profit combating child exploitation
called Freedom Forever
um and that is pretty much what I do
every day mom of three and an activist
but also running this non-profit yeah
one of the stories that's uh picking up
steam right now it's actually from a
couple days ago has to do with jazz
Jennings who is I mean this story like I
I don't know if I want to get into it
immediately but
I I if I were to say YouTube might ban
us for talking I don't know it's I it's
on TLC I played the video so maybe I
should just say it I know it's very
early in the show and some people might
want to you know get warmed up but the
mother of jazz saying if you do not
insert this into you I will do it and
then I will ring your neck like it's
it's it's outright abuse so we got to
talk about what's going on with these
kids and uh This falls in line with the
story of the Democrat who's been
filibustering for weeks saying that not
amputating the genitals of children is
genocide and that that's just the
weirdest thing but we'll get into all
that stuff so thanks for joining us we
also got to Ian's back he's hanging out
what's up everybody good to see you
happy uh what is it a Wednesday I think
we're coming in on a Wednesday night
good to see you guys let's get moving
what's happening Serge yo I am ready to
start the show let's go let's get it we
got the story from the post millennial
breaking 2018 letter States Michael
Cohen paid Stormy Daniels with his own
funds Trump did not reimburse oh geez I
wonder why it is that when the story
first broke years ago they did not move
to indict Trump could it be that he
didn't have anything to do with it a
2010 letter from former Trump lawyer
Michael Cohen's team to officials at the
Federal Election Commission has revealed
the then president that the then
president was not involved in the
payment of alleged hush money to Stormy
Daniels the letter obtained by The Daily
Mail stated that it was Cohen who paid
Daniels 130 000 out of his own pocket
quote in a private transaction in 2016
before the U.S presidential election Mr
Cohen used his own personal funds to
facilitate a payment of 130 000 to Ms
Stephanie Clifford neither the Trump
organization nor the Trump campaign was
a party to the transaction with Miss
Clifford and neither reimbursed Mr Cohen
in the payment directly or indirectly
Cohen's team went on to explain that
neither Mr Cohen nor essential
Consultants LLC made any in-kind
contributions to Trump for president or
any other presidential campaign
committee nor was Cohen a government
employee at the time thus they argued
the payment in question does not
constitute a campaign contribution or
expenditure and therefore the FEC lacks
jurisdiction over this matter
there it goes you can't indict him I
mean this is crazy this is crazy where
is our country going if you're indicting
a leading candidate for president on
something which by the way this happened
how long ago like are we living in the
past this didn't happen recently this
letter is from 2018. so here we have the
actual letter right here you can see it
from Daily Mail
it says McDermott will and Emery
February 8 2018 to the FEC so the
question is did this individual Stephen
M Ryan counsel for Michael Cohen lie to
the FEC likely not it's more likely that
it's been a Witch Hunt the whole time
Democrats have been weaponizing the
justice system to go after Donald Trump
with lies and smears and this proves
that it's all bunk nonsense yeah and I
would say Cohen wants payback because
Cohen went to jail which was really his
own fault he went to jail and he blames
Trump and he didn't get a new job didn't
get money with Trump and so he turned
into an anti-trump guy and this was part
of his scheme to be able to grow his
star on the left being the guy who took
down Trump so he's willing to lie like
Cheney like kinzinger the uh like uh was
Joe Walsh these people know what they're
doing they they they're you know what I
think it is
people like Cohen go to prison and then
you'll see people like you know Joe
Walsh or whatever and they're like I I
know who Butters my bread I better just
fall in line with the Deep state
100 why would Cohen pay Stormy Daniels
130 000 anyway
that part never made sense to me I mean
I think it makes sense it's just it's a
question of personal issues that we're
not privy to right yeah is it possible
that he's just super rich and it's like
130 Grands not much to take the pressure
off Donald Trump I'm just going to do it
for him kind of thing maybe it could be
this
Michael Cohen was he was the counsel for
Trump right he was he was a lawyer for
Trump yeah imagine you're a lawyer for a
client and the client says listen I need
you to take care of these extraneous
things I'm not going to waste time with
them right I'm busy with my campaign and
then Michael Cohen's thinking this
Stormy Daniels lady is causing me a
headache it's my job to deal with it but
she won't shut up and go away I got it
I'll pay her off that will make my job
so much easier now Donald Trump in this
scenario this is hypothetical Donald
Trump doesn't go to Michael Cohen and
say pay her off make her shut up Donald
Trump says you know I don't know what
this is all about figure out what's
going on I'm gonna get back to work you
deal with it and then Michael Cohen says
instead of doing my job filing paperwork
and having to deal with this it's easier
for me to just pay
for her to go away personally and then
just bill the hours to Trump the Trump
campaign likely then says I have no idea
what this is here's here's you know
Michael Cohen here this makes sense
imagine that's what happened they're
they're claiming Trump
paid the money to start McDonald's and
called it legal fees it's entirely
possible Michael Cohen according to this
letter did it himself and then without
Trump's knowledge build Trump for the
payment he made to Stormy Daniels and
Trump was just like I guess we owe legal
fees and so that's the 35 000 that Trump
paid well Trump paid Michael Cohen
thirty five thousand dollars a year
later in October of 2017. there's a
check from Trump to Cohen for 35 Grand
sure and that could be anything though
man when I get a legal bill I don't I
tip it for my for the company like we
get legal bills because of all the legal
work that we do like I gotta call lawyer
like we're gonna file this we're going
to file that you know new company old
company copyright I don't go through
this whole itinerary I call the lawyer
and say here's what we need done I need
this on cup you know trademark I need
this thing trademarked we're launching
an LLC for here get it done send me the
invoice they send me an invoice I click
pay yep the thing is though if I had a
lawyer and and I owed and I wanted and
they just went and gave someone a
hundred and thirty thousand dollars that
would be the most insane you would sit
down
you you yeah
yeah I I explained that already
if I go to a lawyer and say I need four
five new companies formed in the state
of Delaware and I need it done by next
week he goes okay I got it gets off the
phone and then starts sweating being
like how am I gonna get five filings
done in a week so he calls his buddy at
the at the office and says listen just
shove it under the door I'll give you a
couple hundred bucks don't tell anybody
I need to get this done that's not my
fault if that person does that I didn't
tell him to break the law I'm just
saying hypothetically it's it's the
possible I think the simple solution to
this is considering this letter unless
unless you think Michael Cohen committed
more felonies with his legal team lying
to the FEC which I think is less likely
that that's a bigger conspiracy I
suppose what makes sense is Trump's got
a lawyer and he's like I don't hang out
the lawyer I don't know how the lawyer
does all I know is if he's like I get an
email I send it to him I say you deal
with it yeah it's like won't somebody
rid me of this priest and then Cohen's
like I got you buddy I could see it I
don't know you but you misunderstand I'm
saying when I talk to my lawyer I don't
tell them what to do or say won't
someone read me of this priest I say you
tell me what you you think needs to be
done you're my lawyer I'm calling you
for advice send me the bill Michael
Cohen then decided to take this action
of his own volition because it was
easier than actually doing his job
his job of negotiating a settlement or
whatever his job may be maybe he was
like if this book comes out I'm going to
be drowning in legal paperwork Trump's
going to sue her and then I'm gonna have
to deal with that it's easier if I just
pay her and don't tell anybody I mean
whatever the case there's I'm looking at
that there's very little to no evidence
that Trump paid Stormy Daniels anything
is that true yes yes no evidence and by
the way remember stormy said that they
never had sex
everybody forgets this she said that
back then yeah she just lied or
something so we have on both sides of
this Cohen and stormy both have a
history of either lying or telling the
truth in different scenarios because
they've said both things or speaking out
both sides their mouths so we know that
they're lying so these are proven liars
and in Michael's case it send him to
prison so we're supposed to take the
words of these people no serious
prosecutor would take somebody like this
and go oh I'm gonna make this the Crux
of my case to take down a former
president of the United States that's
ludicrous and beyond that you know I
think Tim's exactly right I can see it
now in in the trumpian way he's in there
with Cohen Cohen starts to bring
something he goes look look Michael I
just want you to take care of everything
I got the greatest campaign going on
right now the greatest campaign I gotta
deal with that you take care of
everything else okay the checkbook's
over there and that's it you know and
imagine this Michael Cohen thinking if
stormy does this book
I am going to lose a client because
it's gonna Trump's campaign could be
ruined like there's so many reasons why
Michael Cohen would have done this of
his own volition thinking like Trump
pays me x amount of million dollars or
whatever as his lawyer I get all these
great billable hours I can't let this
stormy lady ruin that for me I'll just
pay her off and won't tell anybody and
now they're trying to use that against
Trump who presumably had not well
literally according to this letter had
nothing to do with it both protecting
Prestige too because the idea for Cohen
was if Trump does pull this off and win
I'm going to get some prestigious job
I'm gonna get to go to the White House
with him I'm going to be an even more
important person and you have to go into
the psychology of a guy like that and
the way he grew up and everything it
doesn't seem like he had the most you
know sort of like uh
you know privileged background he worked
his way up to where he was and wanted to
get to the next level and continue to
impress the person he married and things
like that because she's a crazy lib by
the way
um but the White House would offer that
ability you know in his mind and that
could all be taken from him too I think
that all plays into it honestly your
theory makes a lot of sense considering
this letter I think that seems to be the
most likely outcome not that I know for
sure anything like that but then one day
you know Cohen then says you know what
I'll do I'll pay her off and then build
Trump as a legal fee and he won't even
know what it's for and he's a
billionaire he probably just gets the
bill and then says you know whatever pay
Cohen I don't know he's the lawyer doing
the job regardless of the scenario
there's no evidence that Trump knew of
any of this like there's no you can't
take him down for something that kohen
did
yeah there's no there's no intention you
know there's no exchange of him knowing
that this was this Exchange took place I
don't I really don't like plausible
deniability where it's obvious that you
told someone to do something for you but
there's no paper trail I can't stand
that because that's the the seed of
corruption but at the same time there's
no evidence that he told him to do it
right
so Alvin Bragg osoros D.A is just
lighting fire to this country
for what I think
it may not be about Trump so this is a
Soros D.A so much of what we've seen
from them has been DC comic book
villainy released the inmates from
Arkham Asylum they're doing it all
across the country this may be more
indict the president by any means
necessary to rip this country apart yep
light a fire Watch What Happens watch
everything burn I definitely fall in
line with that I mean I wrote a story I
was warning people about these Soros
prosecutors probably about five six
years ago I wrote a couple major pieces
one in the New York Post about how Soros
was using DA's to tear apart the fabric
of America and it totally makes sense if
you think about and you look at the
micro level on what these DA's are doing
to these cities and changing just the
window of acceptability that people have
about what they're willing to put up
with and what is normalized and what is
criminalized suddenly suddenly violent
crime is no longer important suddenly
violent speech is important okay and
what they frame is violent speech
becomes important and wrong ideas become
more and more dangerous but actually
going and breaking into somebody's house
or their car no that's no big deal
that's just to be expected if you live
in one of these hell holes and I think
that the reality that we're seeing play
out here is these people keep amping it
up time after time and time again and
this guy's just taking it to the next
natural level which is to start the
biggest fire they've started yet yep
that's why people are saying why would
he try to indict Trump on this because
this isn't what matters the indictment
is what matters I've that's why I have a
feeling I'm like okay so he he was
supposed to get it at it yesterday then
it was today now it's not happening this
week apparently but I got a feeling this
dude's going to do whatever he can to
just file it so that it hits the Press
it's going to enrage Trump supporters
it's going to cause you know these woke
Libs to be like screaming it will be
lighting a fire on this uh lighting this
country on fire yeah and there's
actually DC Consultants that truly
believe this is going to hurt Trump okay
I live in Tennessee
and I can tell you this is not going to
hurt Trump okay the people who are on
the fence because maybe they were upset
about the vaccine or maybe they were
upset that j6 people were not given a
pardon before he left the non-violent
ones or maybe they were upset that he
gave the presidential Commendation Medal
to fauci whatever the reason whatever
the reason was they were upset okay
um even a lot of those people are going
oh no this is a line we can't cross in
America this is something we cannot
accept and we're not going to accept
political prosecutions you know what
Trump's my guy now because he's the one
that's going to have to take this on
because they're personally going after
him and he's going to make it personal
and we need somebody who's going to make
it personal and be a fighter against
this and I think they're going to be
really really in for a surprise when
they see how the poll numbers continue
to turn toward him if they do this yeah
we're in the in a kind of a culture of
victimhood where victimhood makes you
powerful so I don't understand why they
don't realize that victimizing Trump is
going to make a more powerful or seem
more powerful he's like really himself
to the corner of the internet on his own
social network barely anyone hears from
him he's it's like radio sounds people
are talking about DeSantis and yet this
liberal media company these people are
still bringing him into the spotlight
the same dumb thing they did in 2016 and
got him elected Hillary Clinton got him
elected because all she did was talk
about them there's some people who think
that this is also intentional to boost
him because they would rather face him
in a general I tend to disagree with
that I think that they're genuinely
still so hung up on Trump and they're
still so incensed by him and they're
still so fearful of the idea of populism
rising in America that they're willing
to do anything to take him down because
of the idea he represents and I think
that's what they really fear you know
and we'll see we'll see how it plays out
here but I really think just like Tim
they're going to indict him I think that
there's no question they're going to do
that and if it's not this they're going
to do it in Georgia with the Georgia
case but there's a couple different
prosecutors all far left who have this
as basically the Crux of their campaign
was going after Trump one of them if not
multiple and I tend to think it's going
to be multiple are going to drop
indictments on him and I've been saying
that for a long time I Know Jack besobic
has I think you did too before on a show
like six months or a year maybe even a
year ago you said you thought they would
indict him oh yeah and so this is
something it was not a secret we all
kind of saw this coming that if you
elect crazy people like this who
campaign on this one or two of them is
going to go and actually do it and
that's where we're at and they'll make
up whatever reason it doesn't need to be
they don't need a reason in fact it's
better that it's this when we're talking
about the Fire Starting method that
they're kind of going after and causing
division than it is that it was a
blatant murder on camera because that
wouldn't cause the type of division they
seek to to to cause you know and that's
that's Marxism at its core you know
dividing people has to happen because
you've never seen Marxism or leftism
thrive in a happy country it only comes
to be in chaos so you have to create
chaos you know it's why it's why these
antifa people look like they're out of a
Batman movie and you pull them out of a
mental and uh you know a mental
institution and the Jokers brought him
out and it's like hey you guys are going
to work let's go do this because if you
look like every time I see the Andy know
post where he's got like 40 antifa
people in a lineup they look like
they're out of Arkham Asylum every
single time dude every time Sr eyes all
up in that and after all God knows what
psychotropics they're they're on legally
and and the funny thing is we're living
in a comic book story man Trump is this
billionaire who who runs for president
to try and fix the problem and fight
back against a globalist elite you know
and all that stuff and then you got the
villains are literally getting elected
with with an evil Billionaire's money
and then releasing the criminals imagine
if you opened a Batman comic no no let's
just say a Justice League comic and
Batman is meeting with Superman Superman
walks in and he's like the alarms are
all going off in the Watchtower it's a
man's like Batman what's Bruce what's
happening and he goes all over the
United States criminals are being
released from their prisons how it's
Luther he he used his vast wealth to get
a bunch of District Attorneys into Power
who then started releasing criminals on
the streets wreaking chaos and then the
the conflict of the story is like how do
you get these criminals back in jail
when it was done through a legal process
this is why I always like Lex Luthor as
a villain because he had the arc where
he is a legitimate businessman I love
the arc where he runs for president does
it legitimately and Superman can't touch
him that's what we're seeing with these
Soros DA's with the left politicians
going after Trump in this way
releasing the criminals is as comic book
villain as it gets
and we all know what's happening I mean
come on I want to know who are we in the
comic book you know that's that's an
interesting question but beyond that you
know when you look at this one of the
real problems is the weakness of the
institutions on the right and the the
you know we'll call it the the
Republican party in general but it's
really sort of the Old Guard Republicans
because they can't say they weren't
warned they had people warning them this
was going to happen and they didn't even
try to fight it they didn't even try to
stop it they didn't try to put up some
independent and fund them really well in
these race they didn't try anything to
try to stop these sorosdas they just
sort of thought hey they sound crazy
they're saying crazy stuff that helps us
because we can cut ads of them saying
crazy stuff and the truth is no we're
not living in that world anymore guys
you let Communists into power and you
let them destroy a country we're not
talking about the ads for your next
cycle because they said some crazy thing
we were talking about this with Troy
Nails yesterday he's a good dude and I
feel a little bad because it was more
like me getting angry and then kind of
just yelling because I'm like instead of
looking at what Democrats do to win it's
just this defeatist mentality about the
2020 election being stolen and then
that's when I brought up you and I'm
like uh uh you know I think it was Phil
Levante who was on the show and he
mentions Ronald McDaniel winning with
harmy Dillon running for for RNC chair
some real change after all this failure
and defeat they just keep doing the same
thing and then I'm like look at what the
RNC does to Robbie Starbuck he's like
this this up and coming very prominent
he's younger everybody's super like into
him handsome handsome you know and
they're like oh very tough absolutely
strong
should be a new voice in Congress and
the Republican Party removed you what
happened with that what exactly happened
they decided that they wanted somebody
else and this is I mean this sounds so
crazy to people they can't believe it
because I've never heard of it happening
before like I didn't even know this was
a thing that was possible you can go run
a race for over a year you can win over
the hearts and minds of people you you
can be just killing everybody in the
polls and all of a sudden some people
can get together
well we've decided we don't want you to
be the standard bearer of our party we
think that could not be a good thing for
us so we're going to go ahead and choose
somebody else so you can't be on the
ballot it's like I thought I lived in
America where people get to vote and
decide who they want I went out there we
knocked more doors we called more people
I did more events I worked my tail off
other people didn't they hid in their
houses okay and they worked this machine
behind the scenes to get the support of
party bosses and then they go what's in
the bylaws what secret rules can we pull
out that people have no clue about and
use that to get rid of somebody who we
consider dangerous and I'll tell you
this personally I personally think a big
reason why would happened to me happened
was because I spoke out so forcefully
against big pharmaceutical companies and
because everything was okay until that
point but when I started to go after
them over what was happening throughout
this entire past few years and I started
to really delve into how they were
profiting on the backs of American
people and on sickness and going into
how we really need to look at changing
things because it's the reason why so
many young people go over and get
attracted by socialism and the ideas of
health care for all and things like that
because we do have a sick care system
not a Health Care system and it's broken
and we allow these big pharmaceutical
companies to start right away you know
if you're a kid on Tick Tock you're
getting ads already for what medication
you need because you have anxiety you
know they're already pushing this stuff
from the earliest stage they can on
everybody and we've allowed it for so
long and that is when they really
started to get angry at me is when I
wouldn't let go about reforming some of
these policies around big pharmaceutical
companies I think it was before that it
might have been it might have been but I
think there's an adult Paradigm a good
old boy system that is very much kissed
the ring you know you play along to get
along you just do things a certain way
but that old Paradigm doesn't work
there's a new right of activists and we
won't we'll won't survive not just as a
party but as you know uh you know our
values everything if we don't raise up
activists and Robbie's an activist and
so that doesn't fit in to that old
Paradigm because that system they want
politicians they want you to talk to
them in the back room about the real
stuff but then in front of people or if
you go on a show they want you to have
these perfectly coiffed and I can do
them I could give you guys political
answers all night that like I'm saying
nothing meaning nothing but it's an
answer technically and that's what they
want from their politicians they want
them to say nothing mean nothing I want
people where I know exactly where they
stand I want to know if I hate them I
want to know if I love them I think
that's what people deserve that's what
our Founders did you go back and read
our Founders and I encourage every young
person who's listening go back and read
their writings if you've never had these
people were brilliant writers and you
have to keep in mind when you read these
most of these people did not go to
school they taught themselves how to
write they taught themselves The Art of
language and you read their writing it
is the most brilliant it stands every
test of time I mean they could literally
write about you going to the bathroom in
a lake and it would sound Exquisite okay
I don't know how they they did this but
they pulled it off read this and you see
that these were forceful men these were
men who had convictions they stood for
something they were willing to die for
it where are those people today where
are our Rebels where are the people who
are Rebel with a cause not just somebody
who's like you know hooked on drugs and
do stupid things somebody with a cause
who says I am willing to go all the way
I'm willing to die for what I believe in
because it is so important we had those
men once and it's the reason we're all
sitting here but not having those men is
the reason why our children will not
have the same opportunity unless we we
actually fix it raise up a generation of
activists Jeffrey witty in the chat
mentioned they were all 24 years old
yeah not all of them I think Benjamin
Franklin was a little bit some of them
were a little older but
yes imagine being you're like 18 and you
own property and you're like running a
farm with a wife and some like you have
a kid already signed the Constitution
you signed that yeah you know like told
the king screw off try me yeah that's
crazy I mean those people at boss yeah
meanwhile this generation's like
well look look here's here's the thing
back in the day the founding fathers
they didn't work they didn't eat and so
when the crown is pushing on them and
taking from them they're like listen I
work every day to feed my family and
then you come and you take no more it's
the inverse now these Millennials are
like look every day I wake up and you
provide so I will do whatever you say
yep remind me again too when we talk
about like the Boston Tea Party the tax
raise at the time it was equivalent to
like
not even not even two percent I think
somebody could look it up I want to give
people the real number I don't know if
you guys can look it up but it was Tiny
now politicians throw around things all
the time like Biden the other day is I
want to add an extra 38 I want to add
this I want to add they want to tax
everything these guys were willing to
die for what was it
was it was a protest of the Tea Act and
uh to undercut the price of illegal tea
smuggling to the British colonies
basically it was going to make it so
that they had to pay more for tea that
came from the East India trading company
but it was like the
today like less than two percent hike in
the cost was it just like the final
straw of a bunch of things that have
been building and building the actors
granted the company the right to
directly ship its tea to North America
and the right to the duty-free export of
tea from Britain although the tax
imposed by the Townshend Acts and
collected in the colonies remained in
force it received Royal Ascent so I
don't think it was specifically about uh
taxes I think it was about I mean it was
about taxes but it was about uh what is
it the toggle passing on the cost eighty
six percent of all Team America was
smuggled Dutch tea right so all of a
sudden the cost of tea was going to
Skyrocket because they were like no you
now have to buy from this company
because they're beleaguered and they
need your sales yeah or they need your
purchases and the Skyrocket again is
like around it what would be equivalent
to today like a two percent hike you
know in your overall cost
today you know they could propose a 50
extra tax on us and people just go along
with their day and they're happy to
scroll the phone and like no big deal
back then they were like no two percent
were gonna go die for this okay so we'll
burn the ships I'm sorry the Townshend
Acts was a series of taxes and
regulations to fund the administration
of the British British colonies in
America and that was a tax hike that
pissed everybody off because then T
became ridiculous ridiculously expensive
what year was that indirect tax on glass
LEDs paints paper and tea all of which
had to be imported from Britain then
when they were told you now have to buy
the East India company's team you can't
smuggle it anymore it's like well now
T's expensive yeah through it in the
harbor and and what we got going on
today is inflation which is causing the
price of goods to go up because of the
supply chain problems on all other
reasons and uh so we can't blame them
for taxing us even though they've caused
the cost to go up we can
we absolutely can blame them yes yeah
look at the Federal Reserve I blame them
for all of it I think Tim and I are on
like the same monetary train and we
don't have enough people in Congress who
are on the same train like I think that
the vast majority of taxes out there are
blatantly criminal they're blatantly
criminal we need a flat tax if anything
that is just very easy very fair get rid
of the IRS just have a flat tax I I
don't know if I'm on board with a flat
tax necessarily I'm more I'm closer to
Steve Bannon on this one but not as far
as he goes because Bennett wants a
wealth tax and I'm like I'm not for that
but you know bannon's position is the
wealthy Elites are ripping us off and
they're they're rigging the game and if
in their favor and I'm like it's very
populist of you I mean it's like an
Occupy Wall Street position he's like
well it's true and so he's like I'm all
for the wax Tech uh well wax texting tax
the attacks the bikini waxes tax all
these billionaires and take everything
from them and I'm like
okay well I don't go that far but I'm
I'm somewhere in the middle I guess and
it's really funny that bannon's got like
a traditional liberal position on
taxation well I think that's actually
that's a lot of populous and I tend to
agree with him here's the thing that I
would tell conservatives who for a long
time defended not raising taxes on
somebody like Jeff Bezos Jeff Bezos
hates you the billionaire class they
hate Republicans more than anything they
hate populist Republicans they hate all
Republicans okay there's very few
exceptions to that rule there's maybe
three or four billionaires I know who
are more conservative leaning all the
rest that are very publicly well known
they're extremely far left and if
they're not personally they allow their
image to be presented as such because
it's beneficial to them so really they
have no values which in turn to me means
you're a leftist because if you have no
values you stand for nothing you're
allowing everything to happen that's
happening with our culture and Society
being torn to shreds and so I'm not
going to go fight for these people I'm
not gonna go fight for for Jeff Bezos
first to be able to keep more money this
dude built his company on a crooked idea
that Amazon if you ran it at a loss for
long enough would build up enough of a
market share to kill so many competitors
that you suddenly hold so much market
share that you can raise the prices on
everything and nobody could really do
anything because you're such a big
business you're undefeatable at that
point and that's what they've done he
did a great job doing it he worked in
game the system beautifully in terms of
success but he gained the American
people at the same time that was not a
true sort of presentation of capitalism
capitalism doesn't present as hey lose
money for 15 years and then let's see
what happens you know like it's a
perverted system of it and so people
like that I'm not going to fight for him
not have to pay more but for your
regular middle class person absolutely
the the amount we tax people is
ridiculous I want to jump to the next
story but I want to show you this New
York Times article real quick because
the context is hilarious
make no mistake the investigation of
Donald Trump and the Stormy Daniels
scheme is serious from March 21st oh boy
that was just yesterday and then today
we get a letter proving that it's all
fake news and not real and the New York
Times should be very very embarrassed
for running a story like who wrote this
uh they deserve credit this is Ryan
Goodman and Andrew Weissman and they
write that yeah yeah idiots well look
you know they deserve to have their
names out there they're like a myriad of
crimes possibly committed by Trump
possibly you know possibly you know what
yeah imagine watching Law and Order
sorry and it's like these are the
possible stories that may have happened
we're not sure we're pretty positive
okay I don't know I mean it's Loosely
based on a true story that I thought of
then added some details later no but you
know what on second thought the headline
actually is kind of accurate you know
why it is serious the idea that we're
going to go indict former presidents for
things like this
that truthfully
no normal person cares about I like if
if this situation was turned around be
intellectually honest let's pretend it's
Joe Biden okay same situation same
details same everything same letter all
that I don't care there's much more
serious reasons why I would want to go
after Joe Biden his family's selling out
to China you know the evidence now that
was released this week by Congressional
uh members who are Republican that
showed the bank statements showing that
members of the Biden family got money
from a Chinese entity that came straight
from the Chinese government and it got
spread across multiple members of the
Biden family which I find more
concerning I find that much more
concerning Ukraine and getting the
prosecutor fired I find that much more
concerning Hunter Biden's laptop full of
300 plus crimes I find that more
concerning I don't find a story like
this if this was going on with Joe Biden
I'd intellectually honestly be able to
say I don't care we look silly doing
this we better not do this I'm going to
come out swinging against it because I'm
not going to make myself look personally
stupid but apparently Democrats don't
have that value they don't have that
chip in their head that goes you know
what I don't want to personally be
embarrassed by this I'm going to speak
out against it they all go along with it
they're willing to be just totally
humiliated as long as it's for a greater
cause in their in their brain and this
is the greatest cause for them they've
been wanting to indict him for years I
don't think they are humiliated though I
don't think they care I think that they
this is activism journalists I mean it's
not journalism but this is state-run
they may be incapable I mean at some
point like when do we admit that these
mainstream you know propaganda pieces
are I mean who are they effectively
working for I mean they're able to run
stuff every single day completely not
factual they don't do retractions but
damage is already done and over they
sometimes do attractions because they
make money on that too so you can write
you can write a news story Ian Crossland
does backflip and then everyone's
shocked and they click it I think it's a
million views and it's fake news then
the next day you run another story
apologies Ian actually did a front flip
and then you try and milk the views the
ad sales you get from that fake article
you don't give the money back no no and
you know Ian is gonna then post it and
be like look I got them to apologize yep
and clicks it's a way of capitalizing
both sides when they do and they don't
always do it but yeah major news Outlet
will write Donald Trump punches dog and
then get a billion views right then the
next day right we apologize for running
the story Donald Trump did not punch dog
and then the right shares the story and
says aha this proves it they make money
off both
amazing huh
but here's the thing about it that's so
dangerous is the side that first saw
Trump punches dogs will always believe
and never be disabused of the notion
that Trump punches dogs they will always
believe that and that's the danger in
the system is that we've we've let it
get to this point where it's just it's
pure poison you know
yep yep I mean what we've been talking
about in terms of wokeness and the the
tribalism in the country is the social
zombism of the left
you've got a mix of people like we were
mentioning earlier Joe Walsh and uh
kinzinger Cheney uh who else were we
mentioning uh Cohen these people who are
like I know it's bunk but boy I gotta
join the left because that's why I take
it to making money yeah that's your next
ticket that's their next check and they
they the funny thing is the left argues
it's the right that does that and I'm
like okay
name me uh
any anyone who was a staunch leftist who
was a die-hard liberal advocating and
yelling Obama who is now coming out and
going Trump Maga 2024. right there there
are some you could probably mention
however if you take a look at the people
they tend to name Dave Rubin Dave Rubin
was never like holding up big Obama
signs he was just a default liberal he
got into politics said hey wait a minute
I didn't know that and now he is where
he is it's like kind of libertarian they
say he was he's grifting you know
because he's been the left it's like no
no no you don't understand the average
person I think Breitbart called them
default liberal yep they consume news
from CNN and from The New York Times
they assume it's true and then they're
liberal because of it then when they
start actually digging into researching
they're like hey wait a minute that was
a lie that doesn't make them
conservative it just means that they
know what's going on in the world you
take a look at these people who are on
the right and on the left and it's like
they had to choose to accept lies that's
the thing we understand when we see a
story like here here's a video of Joe
Biden and he's saying if you don't fire
the prosecutor you're not getting a
billion dollars and he says you don't
have the authority call the president
ask him he outright tells in his story
that he was accused of not having the
authority to withhold loan guarantees
from the United States which is correct
he does not have that Authority
and then when we tell people that these
these default lib types they're like
that's not sure that never happened or
maybe it's not that big of a deal I was
told that but but the issue is they
don't believe it happened they don't
know it happened that's the bigger
problem so so here you here you are
you'll typically find that in what I
refer to as the freedom faction where we
are conservatives liberals disaffected
liberals Libertarians it's like
I saw what CNN said I saw what Breitbart
said I saw what Fox News said I'm I
here's what I think happened when you
look at the left it's like I watched CNN
and that's it so these people don't know
anything
the people on the right know both sides
and then come to a conclusion
exemplified by a graph that I love
showing off liberals only consume
liberal news moderates consume 60
liberal 30 conservative and
conservatives consume 30 liberal 60
conservative which makes sense their
worldviews are shaped by the information
they consume but moderates and
conservatives are willing to listen to
each other to figure out what makes the
most sense liberals don't do that they
only consume left-wing sources tells you
everything so when you see jenkuger of
The Young Turks tweet that Equity
doesn't exist except in the minds of 12
leftists in the entire right wing and
Bernie Sanders is correct we want
equality of opportunity not outcome that
is the perfect example of what we're
talking about he knows he's lying
because every corporation in school has
launched a diversity equity and
inclusion office or officer how could it
be that these things don't exist
yet Biden has an equity plan yet
politicians talk about Equity talks
about it constantly and then gent year
comes out and says nope never heard of
it because they know they're lying and
they're just saying what they think they
have to say to get clicks if you had
asked him the day before Bernie said
that where he took the position of
equality he would have defended Equity
absolutely no question just one day I
mean an hour before he said it I thought
you could find tweets from him from a
year ago where he's like Equity I bet
I'd take that bet I bet we could I bet
we would find him 100 because they live
and breathe this stuff you know what it
does kind of remind me of though every
once in a while the left does this where
they knowingly lie to your face
um about a failure of theirs and they
pretend it just never happened this
happened with latinx okay yeah all of us
raged like I'm Latino I'm like you're
not calling me latinx you guys are
ridiculous and you know a lot of Latinos
feel like it's a slur I wouldn't go that
far because I feel like really things
like you know the n-word that's a slur
um I didn't get like personally crazy
offended by it but so many people do see
it as a slur did I think it's it's you
know kind of Common Sense hey leave that
one alone people don't like being called
it but they just kept going with it and
they put it on every TV station it was
like instead of Latino stories which by
the way is ludicrous like I'm Latino we
don't need our own section on Amazon
this is Latino stories like just put
movies up there let people pick what
they want I find it personally kind of
imagine there being a white section like
White's only section that's what they do
for Latinos it's like they do it for the
Black History Channel they do it for
black folks as well and I I just think
it's actually really offensive like you
know I think it's kind of ludicrous we
need to who you don't think we can find
movies we like without you putting a
Latino sign but they pretended this
whole thing with latinx that this should
be normalized and then once it failed
and all the Latinos hated it and they
started voting Republican Democrats
pretended it never happened yeah they go
oh no none of us said that none of us
like that we don't you are Latinos
obviously I don't this is a couple crazy
people from college it's like literally
the entire journalism changed the AP
style guide changed to saying latinx all
of your different news outlets said it
you had every single entertainment
section in the country change from
Latino to latinx and it's only after
your failures that you then deny reality
and tell us no we're gonna guess at you
you're all crazy this never happened
and that's kind of what I think they're
going to do with Equity because it's
it's just so blatantly unfair and people
are starting to understand how
ridiculous it is that's our only option
to go backwards check this out I just
did a Google search NYU uh nyu's latinx
project receives 1.3 million Grant but
then below it woke let next term isn't
preferred by Hispanics and Latinos from
Norfolk Daily News amazing you know the
the white Libs at NYU really prefer that
term look at this one New York Times
some Republicans want to ban latinx
these Latino Democrats agree surprise
surprise the people who are actually
being insulted are like hey stop saying
that yeah I mean it was always so
ludicrous we're talking about like
literally the most gendered language and
culture on the planet it is a very like
I think maybe a lot of Americans don't
fully get this like Latino culture is
very Macho and I mean that even with
like the women love it you know Latino
women they love the Macho culture the
men love it it's like one of those very
gendered sort of deals and there's
nothing wrong with that that's the
culture you know why everybody wants to
find some fault within cultures it's
just kind of ludicrous to me yes are
there people who are Latino who don't
like that sure I'm sure there are but
you know what the vast majority do and
that's just the general rule about the
culture and it's okay to recognize that
latinx sounds like Kleenex it does
that's what it looks like latinx the
kleenex and that's what a lot of people
are like it's kind of just don't call
people words that they didn't want to be
called It's funny because the left is
like call me what I demand to be called
or else also we're going to call you
what we want to call you yes it's like
okay it's a really weird weird thing
it's a weird set of rules they have they
just recycle bad ideas and then Rebrand
them and then retract what they said
that you know whatever doesn't work they
just throw it against the wall and
they're like okay that one worked they
accept it they accepted transphobia
let's see if it works with latinx well
there's no consistent Foundation of
values on the left that's why there is
such Flex you know fluctuations where on
the right we didn't change our position
we value Freedom we don't want to you
know CHOP Children's genitals off we uh
want you know low taxes I mean nothing
changed in the mindset of people Center
to right but the left is constantly
changing they're the ones that want you
know all age drag shows they're the ones
who want in gender mutilation of
children they're the ones who want
pornography in school so there's no
moral or value Foundation that's shared
that's consistent that's there is one
thing that changed on the right and it
also changed on the left the left used
to be an anti-war party the right used
to be a pro-war party that is reversing
that the normal people I meet out in
rural States and everything they don't
want to get into another Forever War
they don't want to send their sons to
die again for some you know elitist plot
to go take some whatever natural
resource from some other country they
don't want to do it they're not going to
fall forward again they don't want to
spend their money there and the
Democrats love war now I mean they are
literally slobbering for war money and
that's a big change in Party politics
like I think you go 10 years out I don't
think you can effectively be anti-war at
all and vote for Democrats and I think
it's going to be sort of similar it's
that way now yeah I know let's jump to
the story from the Daily Caller quote
we're already in a civil war Billy
Porter sounds off on anti-transgender
legislation across the country
this is uh an actor who appeared on The
View and he said we're already in a
civil war it's a civil war of the mind
they're trying to take your mind and I
felt like that was him desperately
trying to walk things back and it's
because you have politicians around the
country in these states banning the uh
genital removal amputation of children
by doctors under the guise of gender of
affirmation
what I found interesting with this story
it was just what two weeks ago that Jane
Fonda called for murder of pro-lifers on
The View
so let me just ask you guys The View
prominent morning talk show with
millions of Watchers on network
television runs an episode where some
where a prominent personality says we
need the right to abortion
gets asked okay well aside from voting
and protesting what can you do she says
murder and then they laugh and what
would you say she said murder and
they're like she's joking everyone she's
joking and then a week or two later a
guy comes on and says we're already in a
civil war
this is mainstream corporate Network
television advocating for murder and
saying we're in a civil war
at what point you know I I feel like
everyone thinks that a house fire starts
by you sitting in a room then boom the
house is in Flames every single room's
on fire you're like whoa my house is on
fire like they don't realize that it
could be a tiny little kindling on your
curtains and you can watch it for five
minutes it slowly grows and then 10
minutes and then 20 minutes and now the
Wall's on fire and now it's run away and
then and then 10 20 minutes later now
half your building gets consumed because
exponential growth when we're watching
Network television advocate for
murdering people for being pro-life but
haha just a joke
and then later you get a guy coming out
being like we're already in a civil war
at what point does someone just say you
know the house is on fire
it we're in it it's been a couple years
there's been violence it's on fire
oh I'll say it house is on fire it is it
is me it is it's kind of burning down
we're at that it's not just like a
kindling it's not just the wall we're at
that point where we are close to having
no United place for everybody to live
under the same roof and we desperately
need people to put down the Flames if we
want to be able to maintain that the
question is do we want to maintain that
do we want to live together you know
I'll tell Billy this my wife and I have
proudly been a part of legislation we
helped get past in Tennessee to ban
these transgender surgeries their sex
changes it's mutilation of somebody's
genitals and to ban the hormone
treatments for kids and puberty blockers
so basically the law essentially is you
have to wait till you're 18 to make
decisions okay
um I don't think that's too wild I think
honestly if it was my personal opinion
injected into it people would wait a lot
longer or never have it done because I
think that there's an underlying cause
it really needs to be seen But in
Billy's case I will say this
he loves to wear dresses and I just have
a general rule I have two rules one is I
I don't um ever answer emails from
people who put pronouns in their thing I
don't care if they're offering me a
million dollars I'm not answering them
the other one is I don't take advice or
take seriously men who wear dresses
Billy loves to wear dresses so I'm just
going to disregard what he says but in
terms of what you said on the Civil War
Front we're we're at that point where
they have they have lit the fire I'm
wearing jeans
what about what about women wearing
jeans they're cool right they're cool
yeah but you put a dress on I am out and
no actually I'll listen to Ian I will
just we'll put up a wall I had a similar
thought it wasn't that I didn't know he
wore dresses but I I don't know who this
guy is so I don't I'm not going to take
him seriously I mean a lot of people
have a lot of opinions about us being at
War about the world ending about horror
and Trauma and like I don't give a
it's not it's it's not you have some
sort of established reason the view it's
them on The View with him going yeah
yeah and by the way when they said she
was joking she said had her face going
no I'm not and she looks around like
well well no I'm not yeah and by the way
can we pull up pictures of them I don't
know I'm not like in control of this
show but if we can pull up pictures of
his dresses I would like to remind
people if I made a picture of him in his
dresses that this is what the left is an
intellectual okay that they take
seriously but like this and that's and
look I don't care the issue is their
world view is so different there is no
point at which we bring them together
everyone I'm I'm look the last thing we
want is National divorce China would
take over the world yeah well it's
already happening they got to deal with
Russia the brics nations are talking
about working with with the Saudis
you've got Saudi Saudi Arabia they're
going to be trading oil and Juan we are
losing it's happening because we have
you know what man we've been defeated
put it simply China dude we are very
close we're on this mentality is the
defeat we're on the wheel we have a
country run by a family that is doing
deals with China they're not running it
though it's a banking establishment it's
running sure and China's winning and the
Petro dollar is failing and and uh for
For Better or For Worse America's
standing is the unipolar power is done
you could say winning but I don't think
it's done I don't think it's over I mean
yes
or the US Empire is done the liberal
economic order it's really the British
Empire but yeah the U.S economic I think
I think the United States will exist it
will continue but what I see happening
right now is Tick Tock for instance
Chinese company and it's telling our
kids you're getting that dude who's
saying who's who's he does those videos
where he's like leave your parents
Jeffrey Marsh yeah and he's like I
created a patreon so that you can send
messages to me privately you know what I
mean and you get people like Dylan
Mulvaney we went over Dylan Mulvaney's
Tick Tock and it's sad because when he
started making content he was it's clear
he was trying to figure out what would
get him views animal content talking
about Broadway LGBT content and then he
made a non-binary video million views
then he comes at his trans 3 million
views and from there he's getting
Millions upon millions of views it's
obvious all he wanted in my opinion at
least was the attention in China Tick
Tock is science and education so what I
mean to say is when we've been defeated
is that the people who believe in
America the people who want America to
be strong are being fought from within
by people who have no principles no
morals and just want to win nothing
apparently they want to castrate
children they want to sterilize children
they want to abort their kids they want
the government to spend money in uh
indefinitely into Oblivion for hyper to
generating hyperinflation aoc's
advocated for deficit spending health
care which would just destroy the
economy overnight and we are fighting
with them instead of China who's
engaging in the Belt Road initiative
who's doing oil exploration for decades
now in Africa and South America so I
should say this it's not over yet fine
fair point but China is doing all these
things now they do have economic
problems it's not like we're doing we're
in doing nothing but China and Russia do
a deal China is doing oil deals of Saudi
Arabia what I'm saying is that Domino
has been flicked over to end the Petro
dollar and a unipolar world led by the
United States and it's because our
leaders are people like Joe Biden Donald
Trump could first this and Donald Trump
was doing it in the right way securing
our borders bringing back jobs uh the
economy was booming that's the right way
to save America Joe Biden is flying on
Air Force two with his son to negotiate
private Equity deals while working for
the US government and then getting his
brother uh let me slow down while
overseeing the Iraqi Invasion the Iraqi
Invasion his brother happens to get
lucrative construction contracts I'll
put it that way or flying to Ukraine and
engaging in an illegal quid pro quo to
get a prosecutor fired who just so
happened to be investigating a company
his son was on the board of that's what
we have in leadership right now so if
China is expanding rapidly and doing
these deals to subvert the United States
and internally we're just fighting each
other that's why I say we've been
defeated yeah that would be the end if
we just fight each other as the ship
sinks and here's the point Billy Porter
goes on The View and says children
should have their testicles removed
surgically why won't Republicans let us
do this and to me in my world view I'm
like are you people insane there is no
logical reason let me phrase it this way
let's take a logical assessment of what
they call gender affirming care a person
comes to me and says that they will harm
themselves and their own life unless a
doctor surgically removes their hand do
you know what we would do to that person
it's called a 5150 they get placed on a
temporary psychiatric hold to make sure
they don't harm themselves Amanda Bynes
was walking around Los Angeles naked and
she got put on a 5150 and she wasn't
hurting anybody she was just naked then
you get these people who come out and
they've been saying it for years if we
don't amputate the genitals of these
children they'll kill themselves and I'm
like well I don't care if they're kids
or adults anybody who threatens that you
put them on a psychiatric hold to make
sure they don't hurt themselves don't
amputate their body parts that was the
number one argument against the bill we
got passed in Tennessee was we had these
people come in and say basically you
guys want to kill children and we're
like okay first of all that is insane
but secondly what other thing do we
operate under this assumption we say oh
we're going to let patients dictate care
as long as they go and threaten us with
suicide and what are we teaching kids
about the future are we teaching these
kids that if they have a let's say
boyfriend or girlfriend who threatens to
commit suicide that they need to do
whatever that person says and stay with
them to prevent their suicide because
suddenly you're responsible for the bad
behavior or bad actions of other people
and what do we do if it's a kid with
anorexia Because by the way anorexia has
a higher suicide rate than these kids
who say they're trans and so do we say
you know what kids with anorexia we're
going to go ahead and give you
liposuction we'll give you lap band
because that's suddenly going to make
everything better if we mutilate you
further and destroy your mind further
that's going to suddenly possibly make a
couple of you happy
no we would never do that we understand
how damaging that could be and so we
have a responsibility as adults to tune
out threats no good parent listens to
their kid throw a tantrum and goes I'm
going to give in now because you
threatened some do and and this is the
point that I said good parents right
some parents do it's I've explained the
woke stuff as the mother in the ice
cream shop and the kids screaming I want
to
the mother's going okay okay please just
please stop yelling oh you're yelling in
my ear oh please give him ice cream I
had a personal experience where I dated
a girl that was suicidal and I tried to
be there for her you can't at least from
my experience it didn't wasn't effective
it couldn't stop it she tried to kill
herself there's nothing I could do about
it I just had to live my life and it was
like of course me going and living my
life was the day she did it but that
doesn't mean that it wouldn't have
happened if I just sat there crying in
the room next to her waiting for her to
figure it out one day like you can't man
and it's not your fault if they do that
all you can do is love people give them
the tools and sometimes loving them
means doing hard things and things they
may not like you know and I think that's
the truth of it and I think what Tim
said is absolutely true if you have a
child who's genuinely threatening to
commit suicide if you don't chop off
their genitals you need to get them
psychiatric here and you need to get it
to them
instead they're affirming all of it like
if body dysmorphia is a real thing I
brought it up on the on the Rogan
podcast with Dorsey and vijigate because
I I did I've done the research on it I'm
like there are people who will stage
accidents to get body parts amputated
there was one story I read about a guy
who cut a tree down and then as it was
falling he put his arm under it so that
it would crush his arm to force an
amputation because he wanted his arm
removed and the doctors would not do it
is the argument that if you know you
know you get like Whoopi Goldberg and
she's like We're going back to this and
holds up a hanger are you gonna get
someone who's like the body dysmorphic
Community being like if they Don't
Legalize our right for for healthy we're
going to get chainsaws yeah we're gonna
get the hatchets and we're gonna we're
gonna go back to this it holds up a
hatchet it's like what about a 13 year
old girl that says I want breast
implants if it makes her feel better is
that what we're saying oh you're
entitled to plastic surgery if it makes
you feel better should the state pay the
majority of kids suffering from gender
dysphoria have comorbidities mental
health comorbidities or they're Autistic
or they're female I mean and a lot of
them have sexual trauma and they don't
screen for that they Fast Track them to
hormones you can get put on hormones
your very first visit at a Planned
Parenthood and without parental consent
so this is not this is a completely
based on crackpot science this is not
based on helping the child that needs
help clearly they're suffering but
they're not getting mental health care
they're getting mutilation care of you
know hormones puberty blockers they're
getting this destructive you know uh
quote unquote health care that puts them
on a lifetime chain to Big Pharma they
will never get off of those drugs you
always mentioned talk therapy is a
valuable yeah way in and out and around
this whole process for kids like because
psychiatrics is one thing but just
doping them up isn't necessarily going
to make the thoughts that's been the
standard protocol that's what stood the
test of time that children have been
suffering from these issues at a much
lower rate you know given without the
social contagion we have today but
gender dysphoria has always existed
people insecure their bodies every
teenager goes through a phase where
they're finding their identity and
struggling and especially with the
coveted lockdowns everything kids are
going with social media they're having
highest rates of depression suicidality
anxiety Eating Disorders all of these
issues compounding the fact that they're
being you know push this non-stop feed
of gender propaganda I want to jump to
the story from spectator.org does Jazz
Jennings regret transitioning they tried
to make Jazz the example of how amazing
gender transition is all they did was
show how bad it is I want to say a few
things as we start I genuinely and
sincerely hope Jazz finds happiness and
health and safety and
um I feel really bad for for jazz
Jennings she was lied to I think that
jazz is is the victim of very serious
parental abuse or child abuse the
parents are abusing Jazz and and I'm
going to play a video for you guys which
may make you which may you may find
disturbing however it aired on TLC and
because it airs on cable television
Nationwide I would make the argument
that YouTube has no standing to take any
issue with the video I'm going to to
play for you nothing in it is graphic
except for the statements made by Jazz
Jennings mother who threatened to I'm
just going to say it forcefully insert a
lubricated dilator into the pelvic wound
of her child on cable television says
and if you don't I will ring your neck
tell me this is not child abuse and how
this is on television and then we'll
talk about the issue of jazz and I
believe Jazz Jennings desperately needs
State intervention I'm not a big status
I'm a little statist I think there
should be some I'm not I'm not an
anarchist I think the state is okay to a
little bit all right and this is one of
the instances where I think the state
needs to intervene I think jazz is an
adult at this point she's 23. but just
about 22. the state needs to take Jazz
away from these people I'm gonna play
for play uh play you this clip and and
and uh there's two of them actually
this is disturbing you've been warned
with her I'm worried about like her
mental
well-being and her dilation the minute
she leaves my house we have a dilation
problem that is a concern we don't have
that watchful eye they tend to go back
to Old patterns I have woken Jazz out of
a dead sleep and taken the dilator and
put the lubrication on it and said here
you take this and you put it in your
vagina if not I will but jazz is bad
even when I'm home once a day I will be
so mad after machine
goes away in college and that thing
seals up I will bring her neck can you
imagine
I will wring her neck if she doesn't so
the story here is that jazz Jennings is
not using a dilator for those that are
not familiar a dilator is a tool that
trans women use to spread the wound that
is created to simulate a vagina called
the neovagina and they have to do it
forever forever to prevent the closure
of the wound when you get a slash wound
the wound attempts to close itself so
when they did surgery on Jazz to create
a uh it's a facsimile uh it's it's
I don't know how you would
scientifically describe it a a wound
with surgically grafted stomach lining
to simulate a sexual organ they call it
a neo-vagina but it's not a vaginas I
don't think that that makes sense to say
jazz is not doing this so what for
whatever reason Jazz does not want to do
this so the mother says she wakes Jazz
up in the middle of the night takes the
dilator lubricates it and says stick it
in or I will
that is horrifying and then she says if
she goes off to college and doesn't do
this and it closes up I will ring her
neck could you imagine how is that not a
threat of very serious abuse to say that
you will take that you wake up in the
middle of night with an object you
demand be inserted into your child's
cavity and that you will choke them if
they don't do it it's monstrous it but
jazz is 22 so is it just they're just an
abusive relationship that's totally
legal and everything's it's not it's not
it look there's there's spousal abuse
there's parental abuse if a man was
waking his wife up in the middle of the
night with an object and lubricating it
and say you better stick this in or I
will do it myself that would be spousal
rape and you would go to prison for that
is it a concern that if it does seal up
that it will get infected and the Jazz
can die from sepsis or something it's
that you may have to have a surgery
again but it'll get infected and have
problems regardless like Landon said but
no the real concern is that it'll close
up and then you have to have the surgery
again and the real question that should
have been asked is hey Jazz
do you regret this surgery yeah
later it's painful there's recurring
infections and she clearly doesn't want
the successful surgery that is not
successful for surgery so here you have
a human being Jazz clearly not wanting
to do this and a mother forcing her to
do it with the threat of violence let me
play this clip for you from from the
show as well
so um are you feeling like you wanted to
start talking about
are you okay I'm okay I'm gonna cry
but you know I can't get out of my head
I know no listen it just doesn't stop
it's okay give me a hug it's okay I know
what you're going through we've been
there no it still doesn't stop no and
I'm already going back to negative but
the more you're talking about yourself
it gets harder you're digging in and
you're it's making you put a magnifying
glass on what's already difficult as it
is
so this is hard for you I know and you
don't we don't want to push it I know
I'm the one doing it like I know you're
almost enemy oh my God that Mom's a
psycho you're Your Own Worst Enemy
you're the one doing it Jason like my
mind is very cluttered and not clear and
I really want to have that Clarity I
really want to understand myself and be
able to read my own soul and what I want
and it's just very challenging and I
think I'm kind of breaking down a little
bit and spiraling into negativity
I just want to feel like myself like
that's it I don't care all I want is to
be happy and feel like me and I don't
feel like winning ever I don't feel like
me ever do you know that jazz Jenning
Jennings has also started dating women
yeah and that's that that should not be
shocking I I believe Jazz Jennings is
suffering from gender dysphoria a
thousand percent and I think probably
deep down experiencing regret over the
surgeries that they've had and the
hormones they've had I don't know if
regret is the right word because
regret to me would would signify Jazz
making a decision
then later on saying I should not have
done that hence regret I think
manipulated into thinking that she made
a decision because the truth is this
looks more like Munchausen by proxy to
me where a mom has absolutely lost it
and started putting their own problems
in Need for attention on their child
played it out through the child helped
push and inch them in different
directions towards something they wanted
that they knew would produce attention
and now we're continuing the cycle of
abuse to continue the attention and the
child at this point buys it and is is
also at the same time experiencing the
real emotional I know it's my fault
that's crazy the mom's saying you are
Your Own Worst Enemy yeah that's tour
that's the beauty that's to put that
into a child's mind and tell them you
know your problem when you think about
things you take a magnifying glass and
obsess over it it makes the kid crazy it
makes them do that thing and he wants to
get away from this woman yes Landon said
something to me before where she has
seen this clip and she said imagine if
this was a boyfriend talking to what we
have two daughters out of our three kids
imagine for was a boyfriend talking to
one of our daughters treating her like
this saying you're Your Own Worst Enemy
and she's blaming herself there it's all
my fault I know it's all my fault you
know this is not okay in any context you
know like the the behaviors we see here
are very clearly manipulative well look
there are certain circumstances where I
would tell someone it's their fault if
if someone is getting upset I would and
there was nothing to be upset about and
I'm like okay maybe there's I typically
don't defer to chemical imbalance but I
usually tell people hey look start
exercising start eating healthy you'll
probably see your mood improve with jazz
the reason I think it's so egregious
that the mother is saying you're Your
Own Worst Enemy is that it's the mother
that did this to Jazz and jazz is saying
I don't feel like me I don't feel like
me it's because the mom is trying to
brainwash you and make you think about
her dude get out of there I wanna I
wanna say this I will take credit for
this for all of the things the left
wants to make fun of me for for getting
wrong or whatever because I get things
wrong fine I predicted all of this years
ago go what happened was when Jazz is a
child Jazz said that they were attracted
to boys
then around 13 or 14 on the TV show and
whatever that came out Jazz was now
pansexual and I said what does that mean
that means Jazz has found an attraction
to females that's the only explanation
right at the age where boys start to
have an attraction to females and then I
said when I covered this I'm willing to
bet that in a few years Jazz will be it
will be considered a trans lesbian Jazz
will want to date women because Jazz is
a male who is finding attraction to
females low we are now seeing on the
show Jazz has begun dating women
saying like there was something weird
about dating the guys and want to try
something else maybe that's the right
thing
imagine just having your parents do this
to you taking away your ability of a
family telling you it's your fault and
the things you're feeling are your fault
that's terrible all the time but but I
want to stress this the psychological
stuff you want to have an argument about
it fine you want to say no no you don't
understand she's trying to support a
trans kid okay waking your child up in
the middle of the night with a
lubricated dilator and saying stick it
in or else is the most psychotic thing
ever and that woman should be arrested
for monstrous monstrous and that exposes
the lunacy behind this entire charade
this is abuse it has always been abuse
it's why we've done what we've done to
ban it in our state I'm very proud of
the state of Tennessee and our
legislature and our governor for getting
that in into law setting a standard in
these other states who this week have
started to do the same thing I know
Georgia did there's other states we've
been working with legislators to
introduce these laws and get them passed
and I think we're going to make this the
norm in every red State we're going to
make sure every red state gets these
laws on the books and prevents these
situations so that we don't see more
Jazz Jennings situations in the future
and instead we see healthy kids who got
talk therapy and were then able to
reverse the gender dysphoria and be in
love with the person that they were born
to be the natural person that God
created and that's why land industrial
organization freedom forever because we
need people fighting for these kids what
up so we we have this real quick um from
soapdirt.com I'm not super familiar but
while spectator.org does briefly mention
that jazz Jennings went on a date with a
woman this article actually goes into
detail in February about jazz Jenning
wanting to date women and uh talking
about going speed dating and having
troubles and then finding a connection
with women surprise surprise the
biological male of which 98 find
connections with women has found a
connection with women so my my view on
this was
if you have a kid
and you think that kid is trans well you
get about a 98 chance that kid is not
99. you know nine seven chance the kid
is not is that a bet you want to make on
putting the kid through irreversible
surgeries and hormone Therapies in the
event this kid is now 20 years old
crying depressed morbidly obese binge
eating Jazz was supposed to go to school
college a long time ago and did not
because of severe depression right what
I think
my view not a psychologist psychiatrist
no idea I think Jazz has these feelings
inside but knows because of the TV show
because of the book because of Jazz's
family they can never come out and say
it just like a young gay man is scared
to come out and tell his family that
he's gay because of what Society demands
of him because of what his he expects he
thinks his family expects of him Jazz
doesn't want to come out as
detransitioner or or straight mail her
entire identity has been built upon this
you know and that's the whole reason
that she is so depressed she's never
been given proper health care that
that is that you're born in the wrong
body imagine like just the the the
trauma that causes a child to be told
something's wrong with you you were born
in the wrong body you know that that
sets up a child on a lifetime dependency
of external validation so she's talking
about her soul clearly she's searching
for an identity and meaning Beyond this
superficial identity the the woke you
know gender identity your sexuality
they're gonna say oh just experiment
with your sexuality experiment with your
gender and and have surgeries and get on
the blockers all these things and that
path just is a path to self-destruction
lifelong dependency and big Pharma
gaping wound in her you know Neo vagina
which will never be a real functioning
vagina
um this is medical exploitation that's
the proper term for what is happening to
these children there is only one reason
to perform a penile inversion
vaginoplasty on a minor Jazz was 17
years old when this surgery was
performed it is to create a wound that a
male can insert his penis into for
sexual pleasure that's it that's it's
jazz jazz cannot uh feel uh any pleasure
based on the hormone blocker treatments
that is a statement made by the Doctor
Who treated jez that they need to slow
down on what they're doing because these
young males who undergo these treatments
lose sexual function and feeling right
yeah mental abuse so Jazz one of the
reasons Jazz probably does not want to
dilate at all is because it serves no
legitimate function for Jess's life
other than to let a man have sex with
the wound and feminists are standing up
for this the left-wing feminists are
standing up for this where we're going
to make somebody do this for the
pleasure of of men for a man and let
that man also pretend to be one of us
and pretend that this should be a normal
thing for women to do this because I
mean it's crazy this grafted wound will
provide no pleasure for a woman nothing
in fact Four Women
isn't this whole idea of creating a
vagina out of a penis kind of I mean
I've never actually asked you isn't it
offensive absolutely everything about
this is about the Erasure of women my my
Womanhood is not a construct we are a
class of people and everything from the
woman face that's happening to the
Erasure of our actual you know identity
and and calling assist people birthing
persons breasts or chest feeders is so
incredibly demeaning
um so it absolutely like it's an assault
on Womanhood as well but I was just
thinking about you know the puberty
blocker is something that doesn't get
talked about enough that the chemical
castration what do you think a boy would
choose to do if their penis shrivels up
because that's what happens when you get
put on puberty blockers as a male if you
have no penis that does not grow from
puberty you're going to opt to cut it
off because you're working with nothing
in some cases can't even get an erection
the rest of your life let alone have an
orgasm or any of these things so they're
already castrating them but these kids
don't know anything they don't know if
look if if this if a person was an adult
and said you know I'd like to undergo
something I'd be like well okay you're
an adult fine whatever however there's
still considerations we made like if
someone came to me who's 30 years old
and said I want my hand removed we
probably say no to that right but these
children
here's here's the thing I see about jazz
Jennings the reason I said I think jazz
is suffering from gender dysphoria is
because Jazz is a male in a
pseudo-female body and probably wants to
be male hence gender dysphoria Jazz as a
small child was never a man
Jazz was always just a previewescent boy
who underwent surgery and hormone
therapies to become the facsimile of a
woman and prevent male development
so there's no point at which Jazz could
truly know what it is to be a man and
want to be a woman
they they're they're doing this thing
where they're taking a child and saying
look at a woman look at a man which one
do you want to be and I guess that one
it's like okay we'll get the surgery
ready well then sure enough Jazz reaches
a uh the adult age and something goes
terribly wrong yeah we had intelligent
oh that's that's the overthinking Jazz
this comes from your mind being too
smart it's just your environment your
mom has been way too pushy like just
free your mind babe what do you think
happens when imgs gets canceled
oh I think she will absolutely start to
explore the truth so I think what you
said about I think so is absolutely true
that the whole reason she is not
expressed feelings that I'm I feel like
this is again my opinion I feel like
the same thing that you're feeling like
that she regret or Jazz regrets this and
is starting to look at I made a big
mistake in my life I actually do feel
like a male and is questioning what to
do my thought is is that when this all
comes crashing down they are going to
turn around and start to call out the
abusers and the people that lied to them
because I'll give you an example Chris
Beck do you are you guys familiar with
Chris Beck he's a Navy SEAL served 13
tours overseas became the first uh
special operator who came out as trans
did a whole special on CNN he then came
out on my podcast as detransitioning
many years later and this just happened
this year story went crazy and uh Chris
you know I I talked to him a lot about
this and essentially you know the the
book deal and the book being out there
and the coverage and everything made it
very difficult to turn around and it was
bravery that made him turn around and
tell the truth about what happened and
how the military was really just out of
control with this whole thing I mean
when if you hear the whole story it's
insane I mean it was first appointment
within 20 minutes he was given hormones
okay a doctor that worked with the
government convinced him to write a book
to make money on being transgender to
help normalize transgenderism
and the media helped sell it to sell the
idea that even the most masculine men
can question their gender and become
women you know and it all worked I mean
this laid the groundwork for where we
are now and now that very person they
used for propaganda is now today the
person standing up saying do not let
this happen to children I needed to
speak up because this is torture what
this did these kids don't deserve it and
doing it from a place of love you know
he's speaking up because he doesn't want
anybody to get hurt yeah I'm thinking
about if someone made a YouTube channel
about cutting your hand off and they cut
their hand off and they're like kids you
can do it too if you you don't you
probably feel like you don't have a hand
already that's okay just cut it like
that person I would consider danger to
society and I would want them at least
taken off TV not because I hate them
because I want to protect the kid yeah
and what about school teachers doing it
saying remember don't tell your parents
you want you want to remove your hands
we will go to your doctor and we will
get your hand chopped off but don't tell
your parents speaking of prison I mean
they don't just want to normalize this
they actually want to take children from
parents who refuse to use the pronouns
affirm their you know delusions from
from the parents State kidnapping that's
that's already happening we already have
bills in Minnesota right now to you know
have the state kidnapping done if you do
not affirm a child your child can be
taken from you in the United States of
America that's where we're at what did
you guys do in Tennessee is you passed
got a bill passed but what exactly does
the bill lay out what got changed you
have to wait till 18 to get any of these
surgeries to get the hormones to get the
puberty blockers we're not going to stop
the natural development of a child in
the state of Tennessee we're not going
to go and mutilate their bodies with
hormones puberty blockers or these
surgeries these kids are innocent
children of God whether they believe in
it or not even if you don't believe in
that you're an innocent child we are not
going to allow them to be mutilated in
our state and that's what we put in the
code is that's not going to happen
anymore in the state of Tennessee you're
going to have to wait till you're an
adult to make these decisions I mean
personally disagree with it at that
point and think that it is unwise and
Eileen more in Tim's territory honestly
where I see it the same way as somebody
asking to chop their arm off and I think
it's unethical and it should be
something that's banned in medical
practices and I think honestly we
shouldn't go that far well I'm going
further I think it really should end up
there personally but I understand the
Nuance of Law and where we have to be at
and the ability to you know have these
laws stand the test of time and I think
that that's a barometer that everybody
can live with that you have to wait till
you're an adult to do this I do however
think that perhaps it's time to start
having that conversation about just not
allowing transgender surgeries at all or
or treatments uh the reason being like I
said if someone comes to you and says
that they want to remove a body part we
typically say no you can't do that but
there is only one dysmorphic disorder
that results in affirmation and it's
transgenderism I mean there there are
issues of people getting tons of
surgeries that's why I'm not at that
point where I would advocate for
outright Banning it for all ages because
there are people who get lip splits and
tongue splits and I'm like well if
you're an adult man so I I suppose there
really there really is a deep challenge
yeah on the legal front I understand we
win as far as I think you can go which
is saying wait till an adult on a moral
front I morally feel like
people have a duty and responsibility to
not participate in this because it's the
abusive of human beings and and frankly
we're talking about human beings who
have very serious problems in the true
empathetic thing to do is deal with the
trauma not cut an appendage off you know
not cut their genitalia not drug them
you know and if we're not dealing with
the actual problem and an adult can go
into one of these hormone offices and
say
I think this will fix my problems and a
doctor just says yep here you go here's
your here's your life changing not in a
good way adding side effects drugs that
are not even labeled for this purpose
they're not even meant for this purpose
okay what drugs the puberty blocks which
are not even meant for this and lupron's
not meant for this even even the uh the
actual testosterone and estrogen in many
cases have not been tested for long
periods of time for this use of
transitioning somebody from a biological
state of being a biological male to a
woman over a long period of time to do
this in a double-blind way that's not
looking at some sort of you know what
they love to do is convenient sampling
for people who've never heard of this
this is where you put together a group
of people on purpose who you know are
going to affirm the desired result you
want this happens all the time in this
area of medicine so if there's anybody
who's confused and they're thinking
about this look at everything across the
board and look out for convenience
sampling where they lie I I was
wondering where this synthetic
testosterone comes from do you know
where synthetic testosterone comes from
bull testicles no oh I was actually why
did we both think one way to go how is
good guess what do you think how do they
how do they get it how do they
synthesize testosterone
from from what
no gas from a nut
it is often derived from plant sources
such as soy
that's okay it says yams or soy yeah
this is from your Wellness center.com it
says uh testosterone that synthesized in
medical laboratory often from plant
sources such as yams or soy is
engineered to match the same exact
chemical structure that is already being
produced Naturally by your body this
enables it to perfectly mimic the
original source
how about that wow I didn't know that I
thought it was like horses or something
yeah that's soy is known for its
estrogen content or at least well you
can isolate anything I guess that's wild
I wonder where the majority of Peabody
blockers are made if they're made here
or China because I know a lot of our
Pharmaceuticals have you have you ever
heard the story of the the radon girls I
think it was called no do you want you
want to look that up real quick I think
it's called the radon girls I was gonna
add by the way what you said about Tick
Tock so Landon and I are actually going
to uh radio tomorrow
in DC with a bunch of members of
Congress and and the reason why is this
is not just an app this is a weapon no
in China
the radium girls were working in watch
factories and they were taking radium
paint that could make watches glow and
it was this hot thing at the turn of the
century early 1900s and so you'd have a
watch that would glow in the dark but
the radium was very radioactive these
women would paint their teeth with it so
when you turn the lights off and smile
you'd see their glowing teeth and then
within a few years their jaws would
swell up with cancer their mouths would
fall off literally their mouths would
break and fall off their jaw would fall
off their teeth would fall to their
mouths their heads would enlarge I think
about stuff like that and then I think
about jazz Jennings except I'm I was
looking at that that video thumbnail and
I'm like
radium girls
was it dothalidomide Jesus asbestos
lobotomies wow I think in a hundred
years they're gonna look back and be
like how barbaric these people were
barbarians they used to drink they used
to drink Mercury to try and cure
syphilis the idea was the Mercury would
kill enough of your body that the
syphilis would die off and then you'd
you'd slowly try and come back from it
that's key a lot of chemotherapy does
that we're going to kill the Cancer and
a bunch of stuff along with it yeah why
don't you try and heal the body instead
well I mean because if we don't know how
to do it the best we can is that I guess
but the issue is jazz Jennings I don't
believe was ever a human being who went
to a doctor saying I am distressed I'm
the wrong gender Jazz was three years
old when when their parents said you're
actually a girl and jazzed K and jazz is
brilliant and intellectually smart
person I can you can tell by listening
to her for like 10 seconds that she's
got a brilliant mind that's all over the
place unfocused and unfortunately a
mother that's like provoking pain within
her it seems like I'm blaming you Mom
you did this to her sick and you know
what for the record if if anybody you
know hears this or gives this message to
her Freedom Forever will help her if she
wants that care we want to be a Lifeline
for her because I don't know if
anybody's offered that but we will
provide resources for survivors of
medical exploitation of this gender
ideology well Freedom Forever what is it
freedomforever.us that's my non-profit
combating all forms of child
exploitation so if she wants help we are
here for her whenever she needs it but
how would she contact you um she can go
to the website freedomforever.us or you
know people can at her and say you know
contact this or if you ever need help we
will help you think about this though
there was a there was a post in 2016
that was someone took a post a coming
out story what it was like coming out to
their parents as gay and they changed
gay to Trump supporter and it was funny
because a bunch of Trump's voters are
like wow that's hilarious it was it was
because it was saying kind of generic
things like I'm worried what my parents
will think if they find out that I'm
insert voting for Trump my parents are
really against this there they watch the
news all the time and their views are
very much blah blah and you know my
friends will will be mad at me and I'm
worried what people think I thought that
was funny I want you to imagine what
would be like Robbie if you came out
tomorrow with an antifa shirt on and
just said I have been lying I am antifa
100 what would your friends say what
would your colleagues say you know that
it would be very stressful for you right
they would say
um honestly I think they would all laugh
and be like come on Robbie nobody
believes that but like but like like if
you came out and seriously told all of
your closest friends and family that
some something they believed to be true
was no longer true yeah if Jazz were to
come out on TV
to family and friends and sponsors
I'm a guy this was a mistake
that would completely destroy everything
Jazz has I think it would destroy this
whole thing that's going on right now
okay okay yes yes but my point is just
that jazz will not do it she might she
might I pray the jazz is brave enough to
do it and be the person that they were
born to be and to embrace it and to let
people love you back to life because
here's the thing
sometimes I do think people on our side
can be guilty of reacting really harshly
to some of these people as they get
older and it's because we start to
forget these were people who were abused
as children and in many cases have
sexual traumas from being raped and we
do have to have some form of empathy to
the trauma that these people have
experienced and with somebody like jazz
some people are mad because they say
well Jazz helped normalize this whole
thing and it's hurt other people well I
blame her parents for that frankly and
the doctors who lied and acted
unethically well this is somebody who
was abused as a child and is now an
adult and if we open our arms and say
hey we're willing to love you back to
life for the person that you actually
were born to be maybe maybe it won't be
Jazz but somebody will Embrace us Jazz's
doctor has come out saying it was wrong
yep so Jazz's doctor is not the person
who lied he has the Jazz's doctor is the
person who screwed up and they came out
and said holy crap this was a mistake
well I watched the doctor lie I watched
previous episodes like all the way
through I watched doctor live from when
they sold the idea of surgery okay to
the reality of surgery and what happened
and making it sound like it would solve
everything and make things better and
then later seeing what we all see now
with jazz clearly four surgeries later
side effects later damage later in fact
Jazz at one point said she wouldn't even
look at what happened after the
surgeries initially because it was so
horrific
they didn't want her to look wow and
Jazz when Jazz ended up when Jazz ended
up taking a peek
she said it was horrifying and I keep
saying I'm only saying because Jazz is a
female name it's like by by uh you know
just that natural order of things you
want to say she but we all know this is
a biological male and that's
indisputable and these differences occur
for a reason and we've got to embrace
our differences and and get somebody
like jazz to love themselves back to
life there are virtually no resources
available for D transitioners not
medically not Mental Health Care unless
they do digging or find organizations
like ours that's the problem every
single transitioner I've spoken with
their surgeons won't solve their
unresolved issues they don't want to
touch them they will not help you know
deal with the issues all the aftermath
left behind so there's a real mental
health and you know physical health Gap
in what these detransitioners are
experiencing and I would say the
majority of the ones that I've spoken to
work with have sexual trauma in in the
in the genderqueer book we have to bring
up because you know Ian bought it and it
was very smart of him to do so as much
as I don't want this individual to get
money from this have you ever read it oh
yes we exposed it years ago and so what
we've talked about in the show is many
conservative commentators who reference
it never actually read it they don't
know it's a story about a little girl
who was abused by her parents who was
peeing in the yard who couldn't read
till 12 and would wear crusted dirty
pads that smelled so bad the school
counselor had to give her a talking to
like you need to clean your body body
that's child abuse it's also a sign of
trafficking and exploitation and it
results in a person who's deeply
confused and traumatized jazz is very
much the same yes how we save these
people from this abuse is is you know I
don't know because we used to have a
system we created a system Child
Protective Services to be like do not
they're not doing no no they're doing
the opposite yeah you know someone super
chatted if you if you if a kid
threatened to hurt themselves and you
brought them to the St to the doctor
they would enforce the the the
um surgeries they're enforcers now
they're they're they're absolute
enforcers for the ideology they will
literally report the parents to CPS to
have the parents removed from the home
if the parents are even questioning this
in a way that they feel is not affirming
but not they're part of the system here
they they they're the people profiting
off this but they're profiting off the
surgeries and the hormones right one of
the uh organizations that we work with
has one case of a girl named Sage who
was trafficked not once but twice
through CPS after being forcefully put
into State care because her caretakers
her family would not affirm her
transitioning okay so that's what we're
dealing with that that's what happens
when you don't affirm your child that's
what they're trying to normalize they're
not just saying hey let's be tolerant
they're literally trying to steal
children and use our government you know
CPS systems to facilitate this I think
we have to have like a a bigger
conversation as as a country about CPS
at some point too because this this is
separate from this but what's going on
in a lot of states with CPS is Criminal
when you see the types of situations
they're stealing kids and creating
lifelong emotional trauma by taking them
from their parents over ridiculous
things it's really scary it's scary when
you hear these stories you know just a
case happened actually in Tennessee that
I'm trying to help these people they
don't even live in Tennessee they're
from Georgia the dad got pulled over had
a little bit of weed and initially the
police told the mom she could take the
kids driving back home but she's like
well I live in Georgia I'm going to have
to go bail my husband out first she goes
to the the police station to do it and
there they end up calling CPS they take
the kids from her and they end up
mandating a drug test on her
and so they don't even have the results
of that but they take the children and
even if it was marijuana we're talking
about somebody that could have done
marijuana previously weeks earlier in
Georgia and still had it in a follicle
test or something and you're saying
that's good police work to steal these
children create lifelong traumas and
possibly place them with a dangerous
person
when there are no danger they didn't
George Floyd didn't George Floyd have
kids in the back when he was on an eight
ball yeah what happened to those kids it
was him his mother girlfriend and oh
okay no he's not some guy anyway I don't
want to deflect I think you're saying
Jacob Blake yeah that was the guy who
went for the knife uh and who had raped
that woman all right we're gonna go to
Super Chat so if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and most importantly
head over to timcast.com become a member
by clicking join us you'll also notice
there is a Discord sign up where we are
going to have in the uncensored after
show on timcast.com a call-in section
where we'll bring in uh I think we're
gonna do like three to five maybe three
callers we're trying to figure out the
right number I know there's a lot of
people so we want to give everyone a
chance but you can submit questions
we'll actually bring you on to the show
to ask questions of the crew and our
guests so become a member it'd be really
uh we really appreciate your support all
right let's read those super chats get
your super chats in
Colin Stevens says the reason it felt
wrong saying firearm deaths are the top
killer for children is because the CDC
citation covers kids up to the adult age
of 19. ah oh so like 18 year olds in
combat wait so this actually is worse
than what they said there are multiple
definitions it used to be up to 18
because naturally at 18 you're an adult
they changed it to 19 but then some of
the orgs that they cite these statistics
from outside Orcs that are gun control
orgs they actually Define children as up
to 21. when do the most fun deaths from
gang-related crime happen between 18 and
21. so you're then looping in 18 through
21 in with little kids when you actually
look at little kids gun deaths are an
incredibly small number okay and I
posted these stats like probably three
weeks ago because somebody was arguing
with me about this or like why don't you
care about this issue care about this
one and when you look at the actual
effects this is pseudoscience again that
they're pushing the push a narrative all
you got to do is if you're sitting down
people like Billy Porter and he got goes
the number one cause of death in
children is guns you simply go oh fair
point but I mean we're not talking about
12 year olds here we're talking about 18
year olds so I mean what's what's the
stat and how many you know 15 and
younger are killed by Firearms oh much
much lower much lower but you ask them
that that's what I'm saying your
response is do you have those numbers
look like what do you mean do you have
the 15 I understand your point about 18
to 19 year olds and I agree that is
really really bad we should talk about
it but do we have the numbers on can you
guys pull that and then they'll be like
uh well I did this okay when they had
the big George Floyd riots I actually
went to the BLM um protest it wasn't a
riot that happened in Franklin Tennessee
and I went by accident actually we were
just going to get pizza and we got boxed
in and blocked in by these protesters
and I said you know what honey I'm gonna
go talk to them and when it's like oh no
and so I go out there and I did this on
live stream and I just went up to them I
said look guys I'm going to be perfectly
honest with you and no joke I'm not
joking you guys I was wearing a shirt at
the time that said I am Republican okay
I just happened to to be wearing it
because I didn't have anything else
clean and this was like one of those
weekend deals where like you're not in
clothes to go on camera but I did it
anyways and I asked all of them the same
question how many unarmed black males do
you think were killed by police this
year I got answers as high as fifteen
thousand unarmed black males they
believed were murdered by police that
was it nine it was under 30. so and
that's if you take the most favorable
statistics that Washington Post shooting
tracker because the natural thing they
always go where are you getting those
numbers and I was like I'm gonna help
you let's go to Washington Post they
have a shooting tracker here they line
it up completely by armed unarmed race
and go through all these categories
showed them how to do it and I said so
even in the worst case scenario it's in
the 20s whereas the white unarmed is in
the 30s and then they go well what about
per capita and I said well let's look at
those per capita rates where are they
happening and I took them to the per
capita rates and showed them that per
capita the number one place where young
black men die unarmed is in Democrat
cities and so and and I say let's
extrapolate from that let's look at it
for just crime instead of looking at it
by police why has nobody protested this
and the number is wildly different than
the number killed by police and it's
very clear why it doesn't serve the
narrative and that's that's the truth of
where we are and if we don't actually
call out reality we're going to allow
this to perpetuate and continue all
right we got Deborah Muller says
fantastic after show last night great
questions from the audio room it was
great our first few callers called in
and got to speak with Congressman Troy
Nails it was really awesome so I'm
really excited about that because we've
got some prominent guests coming up and
uh even you know having Robbie and
Landon here it's going to be awesome for
people who normally just listen get a
chance to actually talk to us and ask
you guys some questions so become a
member at timcast.com even us yeah even
us cold Deluxe production says moral
courage is is the most valuable and
usually the most absent characteristic
in men General George S Patton a general
from the US Army in World War II and for
some reason many of us quote still true
today
absolutely ready to rumble says when you
order Steven Seagal from wish you get
Robbie Starbuck
I would say like like Neiman Marcus
version like you'd have to be a level up
from like you're like the touring I'm
younger Latino you know you've got to
like add something in there maybe like
I'm like guacamole plus I don't know
something I keep watching actors talk
tell stories about working with Seagal
there's the funniest stuff in the world
that guy you gotta look at look that
stuff up if you think stagal is
hilarious yeah Segal is wild all right
Hayden Lewis says hi gang I found out
the willow project the other day was a
proposal passed by Biden to sell Alaska
for oil drilling many gen Z are outraged
by it I'm for it
I was talking to a guy from Alaska this
past weekend and he's like uh you know
this dude I I mentioned something about
Alaska he goes oh I'm from Alaska and I
was like oh wow I don't think we do
enough development there and he goes
most alaskans would agree with you and
then I'm like and it's probably because
a bunch of wealthy Democrat Elite types
don't want their playground to be solid
and goes yes they get mad because
they're like oh but you'll hurt the
caribou and he's like the Caribou are
overpopulated yeah there's too many of
them we'd like to eat them yeah exactly
no I'm all I'm all with you and you know
what the only reason Biden did this in
the first place is because it was a
political no-win form no matter what he
did because they knew that denying this
was actually going to hurt them on other
projects and that they had already had
the promises necessary to move this
forward for so long that it's quickly
gonna get torn up in court if they do
something they already have enough
problems on their hands they said you
know what we've been hit on the energy
front gas prices were a problem we're
not going to create that problem again
it's a lose-lose either way so let's
just try to keep gas prices where
they're at by giving good news to
development because that's what the
price of oil a lot of it is predicated
on future news good news makes people
happy within the market to see oh we're
going to produce more oil so it was kind
of one of those things they were boxed
in a corner I'm happy they did it though
Nick Napper says you only catch Flack
when you're over Target
that's right
unless you know someone's come to your
house and they're shooting at you I
guess
something happened Raymond g Stanley Jr
what up he says Tim why must you
radicalize me fine fine so they're trash
parents so F the kids too let them be
wronged the poor sweet naive innocent
children as a single tear streams down
my cheek no I think we got to protect
the kids that's the point we do we've
got to protect that but I've mentioned
this before when I Tweet stuff like spay
and new to your kids to stop
overpopulation not a single hit piece
the people on the right know I'm not
serious and they go haha very funny
people on the left just go like shhh
yeah like where's Media Matters Tim
Poole called for sterilizing children
nope they do not care they watch every
single show and they do not care every
honestly you know what you should start
a new segment where you say something
outrageous that they should cover
and then they don't to find out what
they really care about because clearly
they don't care about that they agree
with that that idea I like quoting
things uh in reference to how they take
things out of context like if I were to
say you know someone once told me that
personally I find chocolate ice cream
just disgusting I don't like vanilla
either I like spinach ice cream I heard
a guy say that once and I thought that
was crazy so the point of saying that is
that they'll then quote the fake quote
and attribute it to me like Tim Poole
hates chocolate ice cream
Tony Tai says Tim and Ian awesome show
great job
what the hell there Tony what about us
yeah now you guys are cool too Matthew
Schneider says just pre-ordered Bright
Eyes you guys rock and keep up the good
work yes trash house records.com and you
can pre-order today the song comes out I
think first thing Friday morning and
then from Friday throughout the whole
next week as we normally do we'll be
promoting it and uh try and get as many
sales as possible as I mentioned we had
three we've released three songs all
three have charted on Billboard which is
the Envy of so many musicians who have
been working for a very long time and
have never been able to pull that off
and I've heard every excuse in the book
from the left about how it's fake or we
don't deserve it or it's stupid my
favorite was like people were like the
only reason you got on Billboard is
because you have a bunch of fans who
bought your song and I was like yes
that's that's literally what depending
on billboards by your music that's what
that's what we're doing so thank you but
like the idea is supposed to be that
Taylor Swift gets on Billboard because
every Digital streaming service platform
places her songs on Loop that is what
we're supposed to be happy about that
the machine just says here's music to
listen to and she got fans don't get me
wrong but we're actually fighting an
uphill battle to to do this when we get
on Billboard it's in spite of everything
they've put in front of us bandcamp
banned us Bryson gray five times August
because there's one thing they fear they
don't care if we talk politics that's
why this show is on the air it's no
threat to them the real threat is if
we're influencing people with culture
and art yes that's why they didn't like
John Lennon yep that reaches young
people and it's kind of like saying like
well Tim the only reason you're a
millionaire is because you built
something up from the ground and made a
million dollars like it's kind of like
that is correct okay yes and what's your
next Point well that's what people are
saying they're like people bought your
music who buys music anyway and I'm like
you're saying Taylor Swift could not get
her fans to buy her music that's like a
bold statement about Taylor Swift and I
can I really appreciate the people who
buy my music that's what billboard is
yep so you know whatever man look we we
want to get to the point where we're
success successful enough with it that
we're working with other bands for the
time being we have like a fourth song
coming out in a year and a half because
we're like struggling and trying as hard
as we can it's rough I just watch you
like it man I want you to put it on
while your baby's in the womb let the
baby listen to it when they're three
months they'll know what good music is
yeah Ian's Ian's harmonies changed the
song in my opinion and and because I
wasn't that big on it and then Ian added
harmonies and then I was like Wow and
then Carter moved my harmonies back like
a a half a quarter a half step I think
in the song it sounds it's sort of like
it's really cool it's like three people
created that well at least three it's a
lot of hard work I charted on Billboard
when I was younger and I was an industry
and it's a lot of work yeah I was an
indie artist too so yeah I mean that's
yeah a lot of work goes into that people
don't realize what'd you chart what song
uh it was called only 20. and it was
basically about being 20 and not getting
to you know you can serve at your
country but you can't drink alcohol all
that you know I was 20. so right um
look up your favorite band on Wikipedia
and look at their build billboard
history and they'll have like out of the
300 songs seven maybe like the biggest
bands will have like 50 but most bands
have none like you're you're you you
listen to your favorite musician and
you're like they didn't have anything
like two that's crazy yeah yeah so we're
three for three three for three they
don't like that they're very mad about
it when uh when the first song when we
released our second song officially
under the new record label
our PR person was reaching out to
entertainment being like the new song
from you know Tim Poole featuring Pete
perado formerly of The Offspring we
actually got people emailing back being
like FU oh yeah and stuff like that they
were still really mad the stuff that I
got from press on in the music industry
when I came out and endorsed Trump in
2015 and had you know because I directed
a bunch of big music videos for people
like Smashing Pumpkins and you know
Gucci Mane and all these different
people they actually wrote To Me
unsolicited saying we will never do any
articles for videos you direct or
produce ever again for your other
directors they were explicit because
they were so angry
that's just who these people are they
are so afraid of culture changing it's
not funny well they don't they they know
they control those institutions yes and
we are threatening that structure so
band campaign best keep going yep and
this is the thing by the way that is
very important for anybody creating
content out there we all have to have a
spirit of lifting each other up the
spirit of competing against each other
and thinking that there's not enough
space for everybody to be successful as
a lack mindset there are millions and
millions and over 100 million hungry
people in our country for good quality
content and entertainment that
challenges The Establishment Orthodoxy
Rebellion has always been popular be a
rebel create content and maybe you'll
end up like Tim or maybe even better
you'll end up like me I'm just kidding
no you'll end up like one of us Troy
Dingman says Tim have you or Phil ever
considered doing a cover of Aaron
Tippin's 1991 song you've got to stand
for something I think more people need
to hear that song now more than ever you
know what I want want to do with Phil it
would be great to cover burden in my
hand by Soundgarden with Phil Phil
Labonte singing it because I think he'd
be perfect for that yeah I was hoping
Phil would be in here because I don't
think him and I have met in real life
but I know my company at a time one of
our directors produced in All That
Remains video oh wow and so I wanted to
kind of like catch up on on that history
and what's going on I was talking to
Phil about like what's a good 90s song
that we can cover because it's kind of
funny thing about 30 years ago it's like
it's crazy yeah in the 90s people
covered songs from the 80s could you
imagine if we did a cover of a song from
like eight years ago that's how it used
to be and it's like there's songs from
like 10 years ago it's still on the
radio the 90s were the Golden Age of
Music in my opinion it's like the best
music I agree and I know a lot of people
are like oh it's old it's all no no look
I'm not saying that you have to like the
style I'm not saying that Grunge was the
best music ever I'm saying if you listen
to the lyrics of these sound garden
songs
there's like a story being told if you
listen to and FairPoint Audio Slave was
2001 like a stone by Audioslave Chris I
mean these lyrics are one of my
favorites masterpieces like a stone is a
masterpiece I'd keep her early 2000s in
with the 90s you know like because it
was a different world because I'd say
like sometime around 2005
four or five-ish everything changed you
know a lot of electronics of popular
music at the time not all of it but a
lot of it had Deep lyrics that worked
and explained things and and it was like
you were you were absorbing information
you could say something you had to have
real talent back then too because that
was pre you know everything now is all
fake but I want to say this to anybody
who is Christian and has not heard the
song like a stone by Audioslave you are
missing out right holy crap that song
blows my mind I want to cover that song
and and it bumps out that Tom Morello
did the guitar for it because I think
he's kind of like a wacky dude yeah but
fair point Tom you wrote with with Chris
and your band a masterpiece hands down
the lyrics the guitar everything goes
together perfectly but really the story
being told by Chris Cornell is just like
powerful yeah yeah it was a drummer he
was the drummer of Soundgarden in the
beginning and they needed a vocalist
music was just different back then and
you hit the nail on the head it's a
storytelling because now like you turn
the radio on none of the songs mean
anything it's like they'll come up with
some weird word that just Rhymes over
and over and over again and then they
have a weird flashy dance 30 million
Tick Tock views and that's like that's
it
we're not supposed to talk to people
about that that was supposed to stay
back there no but like uh you know
modern popular music is is his uh is
just more and more vapid every day I
like uh post Malone a lot I just like
the way he sings I know he's what's this
one big hit he's got one really big hit
but if you listen to circles the lyrics
are very simple it's a great song I love
circles but it's it's a great catchy
tune
you listen to like a stone which is from
2001 I believe and he's telling you a
story about sitting in a room reading
the Bible I'm pretty sure it's about him
reading the Bible I mean it could be
wrong but he's saying he's reading a
book that says if we're good we can lay
to rest anywhere we want and now I
regret all the things I've done for all
that I've blessed and wronged I'm like
man so so deep and thoughtful about this
personal reflection you listen to
circles and it's him being like we were
dating but it was just a sex thing and I
regret it and I'm like it's cool it's a
good song but you know it's a little
depth to it I tend to be mean I think
it's a great song but from the age of
Pearl Jam where you couldn't understand
any lyrics
yeah I never understood the Pearl Jam
thing I will say that never understood
it don't don't like I don't like any
part of it honestly musically it's just
like it's a little odd it was it was the
Crux it was beginning of the emo but we
gotta be the Cure we got to read some
more we gotta read some more we got this
from Matthew Schneider says just putting
this out there China's Navy is larger
than ours that is the only that is only
on the Pacific front I hate to say this
because I'm a patriot but the US is f'd
and our time is over
I don't think there is there Navy uh I
don't think that's true I don't think it
is either yeah we have um we have what
22 aircraft carriers and like most other
countries have one I think they're
trying to get there and I think they
have a plan to get there here's what
people in America kind of miss about
China and don't understand is there's
there's a hundred year plan in China
it's very open that hundred year plan
includes dominating us you know um you
guys have had jack on a lot so I'm sure
he's talked about this yeah but that
hundred year plan they're very explicit
about the things they want to do they
want to dominate us and Tim talked about
it earlier in the show like they want to
overtake the dollar replace it because
the dollar has been a big reason why we
are a global superpower along with our
military might and so what is China
doing they build up military might
they're trying to build an alliance now
with Russia they say this is a hundred
year opportunity what is that hundred
year opportunity it is to replace the
dollar and thereby replace us as the
dominant superpower and then start to
make deals in strong arm other countries
so that we're now in the position of
having to be in compliance with them or
we suffer sanctions whereas right now
it's the reverse and if we fall into
that position oh America is over because
it's going to take an all-out bloody war
for it to stop and for America to have
sovereignty again all right we got this
from wounded man Productions he says my
filmmaking friend who hated politics and
didn't vote was contacted by our leftist
friends and was told to vote against
Trump or they wouldn't work with him he
now watches timcast and the daily wire
thank you cultists glad to hear it
I want to say this too I actually do
think we're winning
to a great deal and the that is the
conversation we're having around like
jazz and what jazz is going through was
not possible four years ago agreed you
got anywhere near the stuff and they
would ban you instantly but they are
losing because people are waking up to
what's happening to these kids and too
many young children are filing lawsuits
or or step there's a handful of lawsuits
now from transitioners speaking before
Congress speaking before you know state
boards and school boards and things like
this there's nothing they can do at this
point there's too many people saying hey
this is wrong I also think that the
communization of government is an uphill
battle for anyone that wants to destroy
the United States it's the United States
I think was created in the image of God
on purpose because democracy Freedom
republicanism and like self-preservation
self-control is like the best so that is
on the side of people arguing forward
it's not a challenging battle it's just
you just need to maintain mental
stability throughout okay I gotta read
this well I'm sorry AK storm 49 says Tim
how can you want the fast series to be
so ridiculous but then think of video
game of robots fighting dinosaurs is
dumb also boycott Capcom okay okay this
is about a video game called EXO Primal
where in Japan it was being promoted by
vtubers and in the US it was being
promoted by drag queens
so this generated a bunch of controversy
where people are like what is why are
drag queens promoting this video game
that makes no sense V tubers make sense
YouTubers are characters where that that
are animated on the screen while you
play a video game and so not people are
calling for a boycott I said that
exoprimal is silly it's like robots in
space and then the dinosaurs are coming
listen
Fast and the Furious started off as a
buddy cop kind of thing or not a buddy
cop but like an undercover cop in
illegal street racing and then in the
end it's like you work up the whole time
you betrayed me I thought you were my
friend no brother then they you know
they fight or whatever and now they're
in outer space in fast nine they're in
outer space there's cyber cyber enhanced
super soldiers so the reason I want the
fast series to get crazier is because of
where it started and where it's going
and they have an opportunity to give the
Fast and Furious cast superpowers and
they should or
hear me out Crossover with Transformers
could you imagine Landon would like the
superpower to destroy all of this
anytime we talk about video games or
anything like that she's like I have no
I'm talking about Fast and the Furious
the movie franchise the greatest
cinematic Cinematic Universe dude in
space they got to explore and then they
realize they're in a carburetor and then
they find out that it's the carburetor
of the car from the first movie
that'd be nuts like men in black and
it's like they crawl out and they're
like we were inside the car the whole
time yeah no I'm saying like you know
it's a crossover with Transformers and
then Optimus is like Dom we must stop
Megatron you know wouldn't that be
awesome that'd be cool and then he'd be
like you got it for family and then it's
like Dom's walking slow motion as like
Optimus is transforming and then like
punching Megatron or whatever I'm
driving this time and Optimus is just a
truck but he's like taking control of
the truck Megatron swings a gigantic
fist like a 20-foot robot and then Dom
and Megatron both punch and he holds him
off I'm gonna agree because I love your
enthusiasm I I would spend a hundred
dollars to see that movie personally I
would I would I would walk with 100 Bill
and be like I wanted this more someone's
making that means they're gonna make a
hundred dollars if they make this no no
hold on I will hire someone to splice
together Fast and the Furious Clips with
Transformers to make this movie
it must be done I wonder if AI could
well with that I could help because I
directed the music video for the last
Transformers movie and so I have all the
Transformers footage I don't know if
Paramount will get mad at me for this
but I have all the this we'll release it
for free as a parody by the way fun fact
Michael Bay was my colorist on that
video so he colored it for me wow
afterwards very cool
um yeah I'm sure Paramount Pictures is
not a fan of my politics I'm not kidding
I will I will hire someone to make that
I mean maybe we do like a 10 minute gag
short but it would be amazing and then
like we can have Dom's like eyes glowing
and he flies in the air and then shoots
like Superman or something like through
the air he's flying or whatever fighting
with Megatron
dude you know what I actually like this
now the more I think about it at first I
thought you sounded like a nut job but
now I'm like you know what
that actually sounds kind of fun I know
people can do it because I've seen these
things on YouTube and have them racing
you know like I see Bumblebee racing
yeah if we could bring back Paul Walker
well they did he's in the next I know if
we could bring him back though for this
and have Paul Walker racing bumblebee I
think that'd be cool now what happens is
Dom's got super speed and he's running
and Bumblebee's driving with a jet
engine
coming in like I'm imagining Megatron
and Dom's fists clashing but one fist is
like 20 feet and Dom's a small Fist and
then the light is like a shock wave
what do you want to do right now what do
you think about this convo I'm letting
you guys wrap it up that's we all go all
right let's grab some more we'll grab
some more Super chats here
all right
uh Devlin Foster says from your earlier
segment Colleen Noir said the CDC is
including teenagers in its gun death
stats so gang member violence is
included in the guns of the leading
cause of death for children's stat yup
not surprised they're lying once again
that's what they do isn't it
yes it is
all right where are we at
muffins
and obvious name says coming out as a
black conservative has gotten me a lot
of racial slurs racial slurs hurled at
me by leftists I'm fairly certain if I
am Jazz comes out as conservative they'd
face the same type of sentiments trans
Trader et cetera I'm not saying a jazz
comes out as conservative I'm saying
Jazz just comes out and says hey this is
how I feel just being true to themselves
yeah and I don't think she is
conservative frankly you know I think I
think that the best we can hope for is
that you know they're able to find out
that this was a mistake and that they
need to accept here's the crazy thing
though but Jazz can never be the man
that jazz would have been I know that's
that's what's horrific about these
surgeries and you know what I wonder
when I first saw these videos is I
wondered had there never been a puberty
blocker there had never been a hormone
introduced there had never been a
surgery
would Jazz at 13 when they said they
were pansexual actually have just been a
normal teenage boy who started to get
aroused by pretty girls and then started
to like girls and then later at 16
started to date them and then you know
at 18 has no thought of ever being
confused about their identity because
something happened recently I spoke at a
TP USA event to a big group of people
and this little girl asked a question
during the Q a she's like 12 years old
and she goes uh Mr Robbie I have a hard
time at school because all of the other
kids they buy into this ideology and I
don't know how to talk to them about it
to try to bring them to the truth and
they're just doing it because they're
afraid that it will be uncool if they
don't and I just said quick show of
hands everybody in the room
how many of you guys felt confused about
your identity as a child or as a
teenager every single hand went up yep
and it was part of a longer answer where
we gave them resources and I had my
oldest daughter who's 14 actually
connect with the girl and help her and
give her advice
but in general that's the truth we need
to be telling these kids it is normal to
not feel okay in fact what's abnormal is
to feel like everything's perfect as a
child or as a teenager it's normal to
feel weird in your body it's normal to
feel like this is just a strange
experience and guess what it goes away
you get better all right one more and
then we're gonna shift we're gonna we'll
grab one more Super Chat before we wrap
up Joel drossett says Optimus Prime says
do you know who I am and Dom replies
yeah I do you're my ride that's how we
wrap it up all right everybody if you
haven't how if you haven't already smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends head over to timcast.com in the
menu bar on the left side click join us
become a member join us on Discord where
the ongoing member chat exists there's
multiple tiers of different rooms you
can be in if you've been a member for at
least six months you have access to the
voice chat to call into the show or you
can sign up for 25 bucks to instantly
get access we're trying to create some
kind of gate process so that we don't
get weirdo leftists and like activists
who are trying to come in and sabotage
things it's not perfect but we have to
do something that's the system we have
in place we are going to take your calls
on the members only after show which
will be live in about 10 minutes on the
front page of timcast.com so check it
out smash that like button and share the
show with your friends you can follow
the show at timcastirl you can follow me
personally at timcast do you Starbucks
want to shout anything out
freedomforever.us combating all forms of
child exploitation we're the only one
that is addressing all forms of child
exploitation actually fighting these
issues giving victims the resources uh
that they need and doing effective
prevention-based activism there's no
organization doing what we're doing
right on and I would just say um you
know I've I've got my own little podcast
that you know will do interesting
stories like the Chris Beck one where
not every day and we're not as cool as
Tim and Ian but you know we're telling
interesting stories cool enough you know
um and doing a lot of like you know
sit-downs with uh really cool people
that I want to delve deeper into a topic
so you know you can follow me there on
Rumble rumble.com Robbie Starbuck um or
just follow me on all my socials at
Robbie Starbuck and that's and also at
Landon Starbucks on Twitter Instagram
for all the people who've asked if I'm
running again too by the way they're
just gonna have to wait and see it is
way too early but I'm definitely not
ruling something like that out maybe
even you know different offices even you
know different so maybe the whole
president of the United
love you guys always great to see you
Robbie great to meet you Landon uh I'm
Ian Crossland follow me on the internet
you know where to find me see you later
and uh I am surge.com rest in peace Paul
Walker uh just had to end that with that
all right everybody we will see you all
over at timcast.com in about 10 minutes
thanks for hanging out